e
if opening the um subcommittee work
257 House Bill
257 establishing the crime of criminal
written it's a rather short bill so I'm
going to I'm going to read the bill is
written in we're going to discuss a
couple of different ideas we have for
members so the the short title is going
to be um listed as Charlotte's law uh I
don't recall the testimony about that
we're going to have to ask why that is
I'm sure there's a it's
what oh the little girl okay all right
now I know who that is um a person is
guilty of criminal neglect of a child if
the person is responsible for a child's
welfare and through his or her action or
failure to take action for reasons other
than poverty negligently fails to
provide any of the following so as to
Serious endanger seriously endanger the
physical mental emotional health of the
child and we have necessary care
necessary food necessary clothing
necessary Medical Care necessary shelter
ingestion oh that's okay um we we
started the wrong bill but we're just
going to keep going
because we roll like
um the protection from inges or exposure
of distribution manufactur control drugs
for the purposes of thissection child
means person under the age of 18
necessary care means it that it is vital
to the needs of a child's physical
emotional or mental health based on all
the facts and circumstances bearing on
the child's need for care including the
child's age child's physical mental or
emotional condition and any special
needs of the child a person who violates
paragraph one is guilty of a class a
felony
if the neglect resulted in the child's
death a class B felony if neglect
resulted in the child's bodily injury to
the child or the child becomes a victim
of any offense under RSA chapter 632a or
649a as a consequence of neglect a class
B felony if the actor has twice before
been convicted of an offense under this
section Class A misdemeanor for any
other violation extended term of
imprisonment amend RSA 651 col
6 I.E to read as follows has committed
or attempted to commit any of these
crimes defined in RSA 631 or 639 col 3A
against a person under 13 years of age
so couple issues that were discussed
during the hearing um some questions we
heard from the committee were first of
all the necessity um for the class a
felony or I believe it was class B
felony for the second one um
discussiones representative Shar did you
proposal
um I'm very appreciative of the County
attorneys bringing this bill um uh I I
understand what uh the issue that
they're struggling with um uh and more
broadly I think the issue is uh when do
we have the criminal justice system step
in and really take over dealing with
some
parents uh that very likely are already
involved in DCF process um and you know
which can result that process can result
in termination of parental rights that's
kind of the the the uh the backend uh uh
uh most dramatic result from the DCF
process uh we all appreciate that DCF is
not by their doing uh
underfunded um and um and and may not be
able to address as many families as they
would like to um my con that's on the
one side and I think the issues and the
testimony we heard are it's very
important to address this issue what I
address this issue what I heard from the
County attorneys is why they decided to
bring this bill
257 um is that they weren't able to work
with the child endangerment
statute um which uh is uh
um uh
6393 um and the reason they weren't able
to work with it on in in many cases is
because the statute uh uh read like this
a person is guilty of endangering the
welfare of a child or incompetent if he
knowingly endangers the welfare of a
child under 18 years of old of an or of
an incompetent person by purposely
violating a duty of care and then it
goes on um they said the word purposely
there which means uh you intend the
result of your conduct that's your goal
uh that's the word purposely that that
makes it very difficult to prove in
these cases um my tentative proposal is
to change is to accommodate their
struggle with
6393 and change that word purposely to
knowingly which makes it much more
workable for them to prove cases a
knowingly statute uh the knowingly is
defined as they know that their conduct
will result in the consequences um so I
think that broadens the scope of
6393 and it uh
it relieves us of the difficulties of
sorting through a lot of the language of
HB 257 which while well intended is
really there's there's a lot of things
that are undefined uh I guess the the
final thing I would say is uh I'm leery
of the criminal justice
system being able given the limits of
its resources and its tools to do better
in reaching the the parents we want to
reach than DCF does the the criminal
justice system you know they have they
have fines they have the threat of jail
they have probation but but you know
what we really want to do is stop these
parents from engaging in this kind of
behavior and what would happen if if
they were on probation based on a
criminal charge is a probation officer
would say you got to go see Social
Services uh on the if you don't do that
we're going to impose your jail sentence
I mean that's that's the tool the best
tool they have to try and remedy uh the
conduct of the parents but we all know
the social services in New
Hampshire putting aside DCF to manage
this are almost
non-existent um so I'm though I fully
appreciate uh what we're trying to do
with
257 I think this is a better way to get
there for
now have you addressed this with the
County Attorney at all have you had a
chance to talk to them no and I can I
can do that is anyone here from the
to 11 yeah we flip flop com so oh they
are coming didn't know yeah I wasn't
sure okay you know what I'm going to do
I'm gonna I'm going to recess this until
11: because there's people coming and I
will open the um subcommittee work
session on House Bill
sex trafficking storefront New
Hampshire is that correct y okay so this
is the this is not what we were talking
about earlier so that's
one yeah that's the
one yeah yeah I think that um
we I think we came to a conclusion that
we don't want to study this anymore we
want to actually pass a law um is there
anyone here today specifically for this
law would you i' like to address all of
up what we're interested in right now is
we we want to write a law to um so we
we're all set with the study committee
so any language that you have um we'd
it good morning rep um representatives
and chairman Roy thank you for allowing
me to speak on this matter of Charles
foot from Derry representing Rockingham
13 um I am a State Rep but also a town
counselor in that town um as you know we
we testified before you last week this
is a real concern in der and Statewide
and as you heard from other testimony
this is an international issue and
um sorry that's my medical alarm going
off um
and we also concur this is a this is a
bill that needs to have some affirmative
action um sooner than later as as you've
heard last week There's the communities
around us the states around us um in New
England had make it a class B felony I
believe for anyone who Harbors these or
knowingly allows these business to
happen so that's what I would encourage
this committee to do is make an
amendment so we can pass that law and
make this a felony so we can really um
put a a stop to this um and I'll leave
it at that that's you you have all the
information Before You and I
what's going on in your community what
are you getting for feedback from law
enforcement as far as why they are not
able to do anything right
now
so the the the basically because there's
really nothing that sticks you know they
go in there and it's such a lowlevel
offense and I'm paraphrasing um that's
fine coincidentally I do have a meeting
with the chief um upcoming and the Town
Administrator about this um I did speak
with Homeland Security agents last week
as well yeah and essentially it's just
it there's not enough teeth in it to
have anything stick and it's and
basically it's a it's a misdemeanor
crime level offense and these um actors
they just keep moving around from
location to location the the girls from
what I'm aware of the the ladies
involved in this business they get
cycled out every 10 days or so so they
it's always it's hard to hit a moving
Target essentially yeah so
um that that's the the nuts and bolts of
it it's just there's not enough teeth to
have anything stick to make this
worthwhile going in and um and I'll let
the Town Administrator address it
further if he has any more technical
aspect to it but that's what it comes
down to um there has been some
discussion in the past about maybe
empowering oplc to be able to go in uh
under the massage licensing and do snap
unannounced
inspections um and which would it the
problem with that is is when you do a
regulatory inspection and you you use it
for the purpose of getting law
enforcement information the regulatory
then becomes the agent of the state and
they are for all intents and purposes
law enforcement and they need a search
warrant so it's really difficult to use
one to get to the other um but we we'll
take we'll take that on advisement we're
going to come up with something right
um so just may i' also representative
jod Nelson and I met with oplc last year
MH and you know basically the
understaffing and the the amount of
volume of what they deal with yeah this
basically was outside of that purview so
again there's that they said essentially
there's nothing we can really do and and
with these um parlors opening up on Body
Works which which was a license out of
New York it does become a licensing
issue because um is it a reciprocity
issue so how does the town how does the
state or the town regulate those coming
in yeah like who oversees that so that's
a big concern um and then we end up
having to create a whole new bureaucracy
OB right so it just it seems like you
know at for the lay person oh this is
easy fix yeah but it's not it's really
not it's it's really convoluted and that
we need to really we need to hone in on
it and and make this a serious offense
and crack down on it okay so I thank you
for your time I appreciate it thank you
would you like to speak to town ad
Ministry you don't have to only if you
want
to represent sh did you have a comment
or yeah I was I was wondering what it be
I think it'd be very useful I I remember
from last week the testimony from the
two people from Homeland Security that
they were very committed to taking
action and not having a study committee
and you know it I I suggest it might be
very useful if you all were to get
together with the homeland security
people and talk through exactly what you
want to propose so there's coordination
that I was just going to say I think
they literally had a list of of
suggestions so that would be super
help good morning I'm Dave Karen the
Town Administrator and Derry thank you
for your time working on
hb45 speaking with Chief fioli the
frustration is is that there are
language barriers in refusal to
cooperate for the workers who are
actually operating in these massage
parlors so we think there's really a a
three prong approaches one is that a
Statewide database for licensure no
reciprocity and that if if uh if uh a
female works one she has to be licensed
to that location only because we're find
that jumping from Community to community
so doing it on individual Community
basis has not been very effective also
what's really be effective is what uh
pamer has proposed here is to have the
landlord assume some responsibility for
who's occupying their premises we found
that's been very successful in other
states uh and has really really uh
slowed down the proliferation of these
activities yeah I would I would assume
once you have some skin in the game as
far as losing potentially losing some
real estate um you're going to be much
more careful about what goes on in your
and at the F FY level it tends to get
the landlord's attention yeah okay great
thank you for that input thank you yeah
and uh congratulations on your Police
Department being accredited one the
first one in state
good morning um so we're from the
Coalition um so page two I think is
really what speaks to of the handout I
gave you and um can email copies to the
rest of the folks here um page two I
think really speaks to that taking
action component um as something that we
could do this year um that immediately
would speak to what has been brought
forward this morning we weren't sure if
there were still sort of if if help if
having a study commission still could
help move or continue the conversation
to to have further uh legislative action
um but this yeah yeah so I think we just
didn't know what the committee would be
most favorable or what would be most
strategic in terms of continuing
ensuring that we really address this
issue um I think as the Town
Administrator stated um it really helps
when you have both a law enfor M but
also a regulatory approach and I think
that's something we should continue to
explore um I know in the past and I have
copies of the bills from a couple of
years ago there's been the effort for
the lenser piece I think while I agree
or understand where we don't want to
make the oplc another law enforcement
agency the ability to regulate and just
be able to go in and say hey you're not
in compliance with all of these Health
codes um the people in this don't
actually have licenses can help add um a
level of insance uring that all of these
businesses are doing what they're
supposed to be doing which is legitimate
massage practices um and so I think
right now um massage um these illicit
businesses are only identified through
complaints and reports to law
enforcement and it and sometimes to the
oplc but action cannot be taken unless
those concerns are raised um is my
understanding um but so page two um
really speaks to an area in the
prostitution statute that we can really
focus on the business practice um and
you know I understand I may not have
written it correct um fully um but this
was my attempt you mean in Legally in in
Legally um my my uh non-existent law
degree but I did my very best um to
highlight the main issue which is
paragraph e which is currently a
misdemeanor um if we raised um it to a
felony and then I I did note that there
is already a clause about um involving
uh minors and so I did bring that in if
there was interest to also you know make
that a more severe penalty again to give
some more teeth um or we could just make
it a felony and leave it at that um so I
think there's some flexibility here but
this is really what's been identified as
the key way um to I address it um it's
not you know creating a lot of felonies
within the prostitution statute it's
really narrowing in on that one piece
that's been really
challenging okay a couple things I think
that we can um we can do two things so I
think I I like the idea of creating a
commission not a not a committee a
commission and have it be broad so that
it covers uh human trafficking period
not just necessarily in this aspect but
in all aspects because we're dealing
with it on several levels dealing on
immigration we're dealing with it on um
you know missing children we're dealing
with it in this and I I think that it's
um it's worthy of having an ongoing uh
commission that can keep track of the
various changes going on in federal and
state law and intelligence that's coming
in so that we're Nimble enough to change
our statutes as we need to um so I think
that that's okay to do both I I think um
we would definitely we like I think part
of the reason we wanted to be
hyperfocused on this particular issue is
because there are a lot of different
stakeholders and agencies that are
trying to address it from multiple
angles um and the task force like so New
Hampshire does already have a task force
that is multi-disciplinary and has you
know Homeland Security folks prosecutors
crisis center Advocates and so on so I
just don't want to add take have
parallel work from what the task force
is already doing to address these things
but I I hear what you're saying and yeah
does the task force have anyone from the
legislature involved in
it not currently
no but no so I think that's a do you
want to speak to how they could join
sure yeah it would be helpful just
because we don't know what's going on so
then we hear yeah I think that makes a
lot of sense the task force is kind of
in the process of restructuring I don't
know how much members of this committee
are aware um the taskforce as of this
budget period is state funded rather
than F funded by federal grants um and
as part of that process the Attorney
General commissioned um A needs
assessment a Statewide needs assessment
which has just completed uh so their
office has seen the results of that we
have not yet as a task force so we know
we will likely be changing structure we
don't quite know how yet um but we are
certainly hoping for more buying from
stakeholders at the state level now that
we are a fully state funded and on top
of that um Meg and other members of the
task force have been working with the
AG's office to create a human
trafficking uh protocol in the state so
that everyone could follow um when
addressing these cases so I think the
hesitancy is not because we don't report
looking into this issue but we know that
there's a few moving pieces right now
that might lend itself to helping shape
future legislation on a larger like on a
bigger picture I'm just trying to
balance the difference between a
commission and a committee got and a
commission is an ongoing thing so if I
if I just hyper focus it on this one
issue it's kind of um that that's a not
to make light of it but it's a small
issue for an ongoing thing that has no
end so I could do a commission with an
end date of two years or something like
that if we're going to hyperfocus it and
then I think because I think that could
help leverage some of the conversations
that are already happening within the
task force and these other agencies and
I have a question about massage um
licensing and I know it's probably not
your expertise but maybe you've picked
it up in dealing with this each of the
individual massage therapists are
supposed to be licensed correct I
believe that's correct Pamela yes but
the business but the business overall is
not yes that is that's correct and that
so that's the kind of the Crux of the
issue is that um in New Hampshire some
um bit like some uh professions have to
be both individually licensed and then
the establishment is licensed but in New
Hampshire it the establishment isn't but
individuals are um for massage and like
other Body Works um and so that's sort
of what we're trying
to kind of regulate a little bit because
uh sometimes the people who are
operating in these illicit businesses
aren't actually the ones that are
licensed
and so and then it just it doesn't
that's what I'm assuming I understand
that they I mean it's not an easy
license to get or maintain I think they
continuing ed classes and all kinds of
things so I'm assuming that these people
that are in here that are rotating
around aren't licensed therapists so as
oplc unable to go in there and check
their
licenses or or the local Health
Department yeah I could definitely I
know they've testified in the past on
the establishment piece um so I could
look back at their past testimony just
to see where they're coming from that
angle um but I I think I think there's a
there's a little bit of a disconnect
about like actually being able to go in
and and regulate the business and versus
the license of the individuals
representative Ro did you have something
to add to this because I know you looked
at this and worked on this
before thank you Mr chairman I I I think
I do
so okay so in the committee when when we
heard the comment that was made that
well maybe a landlord could say if you
don't like basically saying that you
like you have to let them in or else
we're going to like terminate your lease
or whatever that that would be that
would be like a no starter right you
can't a landlord can't say what the
tenant has to do if it's
unconstitutional like you just can't let
somebody come into your business you're
going to lose your
lease however so if the if the if the
employees are supposed to be licensed
and have a license on the wall that
they're identified as that particular
person right if if the state has the
ability to go in and do a you know a
spot check per se which now they don't
have the ability to do that then that
would be one thing right if there's 20
people here and there's only seven
people's names up on the wall there's
there's clearly an issue right there
right and then additionally
if if it was where all right you're
licensed for
this location not this location right so
if it's the thought of well I'm just
going to pack up in the middle of the
night and go to another location because
they're on to me for lack of better word
that would prevent that because you're
only allowed to be right here and if you
want to go there then that establishment
would have to be inspected per se before
it could be opened right it would that
be like the general idea of and then by
the time you catch on they Peck up and
they're gone or they're shipped
someplace else right yeah and I think I
just wanted to Circle back too that you
know as far as the individual lure I
think that comes again back to the issue
of then the infraction is on that
individual massage therapist who likely
is a victim of trafficking so I think
that's a big part of it for us and so I
think part of it is like really holding
the business like the people operating
them accountable well in other words you
can charge the the person running the
business with hiring unlicensed
therapists versus going after the
therapist and as far as limiting the
licenses to geography that would be
problematic because you can't say you're
only licensed in this town but I believe
we could
enable enable um
municipalities to require some type of
either licensing or registration for
them to operate in the in the so that
their health department could
theoretically get involved and go check
licenses as well so there's several
levels that we could look at this film
question one could write a statute that
um that with language that uh uh puts a
burden on a landlord uh that one way to
do it I mean there's cases out there
that talks about charging a landlord as
an accomplice uh and and really what
matters there is their mental state so
yeah you know if uh you could write a
statute such that uh if they uh if they
were aware of what's going on uh that it
they could be charged as an accomplice
that's really not hard to write the
issue is could would you want to put in
that statute an obligation on their part
to uh know what's going on so that
that's the soft spot on that second um
you know oplc as a general matter is uh
and I don't mean this in a negative way
but they're a a passive operation they
take licenses away when somebody reports
a violation to them they've never done
investigations on their own they
proactively they just don't that's not
what they've done historically and God
knows they don't have the resources to
do that uh last thing have have you all
talked to Homeland Security I was just
going to circle back to that yes so we
work closely on the task force with the
the homeland security officers they were
uh would have liked to be here today um
one of them has just started a new Chief
role in New Durham so he's busy with
that and the other's on a pre-arranged
uh vacation but this the second page of
what Pamela has provided is really what
um Task Force officer Mal was speaking
to the most with us as far as the
challenge of a this being uh the kind of
ownership or control of the
establishment being a felony in
Massachusetts and not here so seeing
that influx he also did speak to the
challenge of that knowingly piece we had
a look and the other standards don't
seem like they fit any better there for
that I'm not sure yeah and and that's a
matter that's a just to follow up on
that in one more piece you know that's a
matter of the word we put in there I
mean we can charge we can say that a
landlord is accomplice if they act
recklessly that they you know they
don't yeah there's language um
um I had another brilliant point but I
forgot yeah we would definitely be
amendable if there was a different word
than knowingly um like what um
representative Sher is saying so we
we're flexible with that piece of it I
had a a question for the town of
Derry you I'm just trying to brainstorm
ways that did you hear what I had
mentioned about a local um some type of
local license or registration for or
massage therapist if we were to empower
municipality to to enable that something
where your health department could go in
and check licenses um whereas oplc
doesn't have the Staffing or or the time
or
expertise thank you represent we do have
a full-time Health officer in Derry so
that would help dery itself I just don't
know how many communities help full-time
Health officers yeah no it would be it
would be an option not a mandate so it
would be a tool um maybe that would help
yeah yes I remember my other brilliant
Point um it would be helpful regardless
of what else happens that that the task
force consider having a legislator on
there because it it it really uh it
improves the flow from what the task
force doing ideas that come up to what
we we are trying to do
here yeah so if you want to drop that in
somebody's ear that might be that's the
somebody it's it's in your ear you did
it very good thank you all right anyone
else want to address us on this I think
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
start a craft um I'm going to craft a a
a white a sheet and we'll we'll start
circulating and see what we can get for
ideas and we'll uh I'll set a date we'll
come back in uh in a couple weeks and
um let you know where we're at and be
prepared to submit to the full committee
uh a piece of legislation yeah we just
really appreciate your dedication to
this because it really needs to be and
we were really hoping that we wouldn't
spend another year studying without
taking at least some action so we're
just really grateful for all of your
consideration I I dislike study
committees because they just don't have
the time to do anything when you look at
it logistically they don't finish and
get ready to start their work until
September and they only have till
November and I just don't feel like that
lends itself to a good work product and
um I don't think the speaker likes them
either so we're going to we're going to
come up with some actual legislation um
if anyone wants to reach out to me in
the meantime if they have another
brilliant idea or thought um you you
know how to get in touch with me um so
um just keep your eyes peeled for when
the next meeting is if you want to come
and uh we'll we'll hopefully have a
piece of legislation thank you and with
that I close that one and the next one
I'm reopening is yeah I racist it what
is it um 257 um reopening House Bill 257
yeah okay so when we last left off uh
representative Sher had proposed a
change to RSA
6393 and we were interested in actually
running this by the County
attorneys I think that that's a a
capital idea um and if they think that
that would accomplish it that would be
much simpler and cleaner
so yeah I was hoping they were going to
be here are we early
noly to start at
11: what time is it 10:33
105 I'm on a different time zone I know
all right so the the the hearing that I
opened an hour early I'm going to recess
11:
e
reopening the subcommittee work session
on House Bill 257
and I believe we wanted to hear from the
County
attorneys it's my understanding there's
a a a bill very similar in in the Senate
right now
um and I was wondering what your
that I've looked at that previously I
don't have it in front of me so I don't
have the direct language so it's hard to
to make an intelligent conversation uh
but based on just speaking with the
office of the the child guardian I think
part of the problem is there's not a
mental state in there and I think even
that and representative Shear's proposed
amendment to changing the endangering
the welfare it put default to a knowing
mental state and a lot of the conduct
we're looking to address here is not a
knowing mental state it's not someone
who has an idea that their actions are
going to cause this result m M and so I
think we're still going to end up in the
same position where a lot of this
conduct just falls through the cracks
and yes changing it in 169c May mean
that DCF has different Avenues to go
down but it does not provide a law
enforcement no it does not provide a law
enforcement angle uh and so it sort of
leaves us in a spot where we can't do
anything and leaves us exactly where we
are and to demonstrate the examples know
the mental States for criminal are uh
purpose knowingly recklessly and
negligently knowingly would be a lot
harder to prove obviously and if you
have a situation where um a parent has
left drugs out uh and a child inest said
drugs and is seriously injured um that
might be not a knowing mental state they
might not have known that certain
conduct would result as a as a result of
their act so would that be negligence
gross negligence exactly it would be
negligence same with if you had a um
significant other that you were aware of
has a um a past behavior of sexually AB
children you left them with your own
children unattended you might not know
that that conduct is going to result but
if it does result it's because you took
a substantial and unjustifiable risk
that your child would be sexually
assaulted and if in fact they were
sexually assaulted that would be
negligent and not knowingly okay um I I
had another question with regard to our
statutes around manslaughter I know a
lot of states have uh a a depraved
indifference standard for manslaughter
in other words you leave out drugs you
should have known um that shows depraved
indifference do we have something like
that how do how would you charge on on a
case like that so that would be a
negligent homicide so there's a
manslaughter but there's also negligent
homicide too I think that would more
appropriately fit the uh negligent
homicide standard um and it's a
substantial and unjustifiable risk but
like we talked about last week if you
had a child that injested drugs that did
not die yeah there would be no Avenue to
charge that individual so they could
have permanent brain damage Andre that
person's not going to get charged
correct we could kind of try to twist it
to fit into a reckless conduct with a
deadly weapon statute but whether or not
drugs constitute a deadly weapon juries
have trouble wrapping their brains
around titles of stat they can see when
you're walking on a tight rope yeah and
that is something that's happening you
way I there's a case for review in my
office where just that happened a child
ingested drugs ultimately that child was
able to be revived and is largely okay
but it does not fit really anywhere else
unless we sort of strong arm it into a
reckless conduct that weapon and I don't
see that scenario fitting in The Knowing
standard um for the amendment of
endangering the welfare of a child that
representative sure put forward uh or
the uh amended I think it's s sp23 yes
that's right oh that's helpful um and
that wouldn't pertain to that fact
pattern as well um and this is a knowing
mental state it does it gets read of the
word purposely uh so it is still a
knowing mental state so it's very
similar in that regard to representative
Shear's amendment to and the state that
you're looking for to be clear
is we're looking the bill we proposed uh
is a negligent NE okay would that apply
we talk a lot about drugs um there's a
lot of other scenarios like leaving a
firearm around with would this be the
same type of thing or having a dangerous
animal that attack we've had several
cases of children being attacked by
dangerous animals that people possess
same type of
scenario uh yes I think so there's
actually on the books a negligent
storage of firearms that pertain to
leaving a loaded firearm within a
child's reach unlocked um if a child I
could see a fact pattern in which you
could fit that into um like a a child
being around a firearm doesn't know how
to use a firearm it's loaded is Gravely
injured or injures a friend I think that
would fit this particular fact pattern
okay I'm just trying to think of
different scenarios that would be caught
into this okay was there anything else
you wanted to tell us um I think we
would just um like to emphasize that
though there is a civil Avenue that's
being sought by the um Office of the
child advocate in DCF to amend that
statute that that doesn't mean there
doesn't need to be a criminal statute as
well there's a lot of issues with uh how
um the time frames for dcyf can prolong
uh the situations where children's CH
children are placed in danger where uh
having an Avenue to charge somebody
criminally gives us a lot of options as
well for for helping and I think what we
emphasized last week is this would be a
deterrent and a big deterrent um for
people to to um take I think you also
testified last week that it it's not
only about the the stick it's also a
little bit of carrot as well as you can
get them into the system and offer them
exactly so for example in straford
County um if we charge somebody with a
crime and they are placed on bail we
have a host of services that we can
provide that individual on bail to not
only make sure that they comply with
their bail recommendations and not
commit any other crimes but help them
get mental health treatment drug uh
substance abuse treatment all things
that can help them um with their dcyf
plan to reunify but also have a check on
them to make sure they're doing it and
have a supervisor assigned to make sure
they're doing it who will inform the
court immediately if they're not doing
it um which can help us again protect uh
the children that are hope hopefully not
left in their care but it's sometimes
left in their care okay thank you I
would also uh just note to the extent
that there are different definitions in
one 169c versus the bill that's been put
forward from our perspective that
doesn't raise an issue uh
prosecutors would be looking at the
criminal definition and I would note
that the definitions throughout the
criminal code are inconsistent uh if you
look at child under the sexual assault
statute a child is defined as somebody
under the age of 16 if you look at child
under the child sexual abuse material
child is defined as under 18 so there
are inconsistent definitions for these
words within the criminal code that we
already every single time you go to
charge something need to go back to the
definitions and make sure you're within
the process proper framework so to the
extent that it's a different chapter of
the statutes does not align perfectly
with the criminal code I don't think
that that's a significant concern well I
I would suggest to you that if um you
happen to have yourself a summer intern
and you put them to work and give me a
list of el those definitions you need to
have fixed I'd be happy to submit a bill
to do that thank you thank you yeah are
there any questions from members that
would like to ask to elucidate some
information that we don't already know
seeing none thank you very much anyone
else want to address the committee
officer were you here or did you want to
talk Chief I based on the Stars I'm
going with Chief good morning chairman
Roy and the members of the committee my
name is Alex Lee I'm the chief of police
in Newport uh detective Marvin wanted to
be here this morning but uh late last
night he was uh involved in the arrest
of a child protection child predator
situation so uh I told him he needed to
stay home get his work done but um I've
been a police officer in New Hampshire
for 21 years I was a detective for the
State Police um before going into local
law enforcement and becoming a chief and
my whole career I've specialized in
child protection cases uh so I just
wanted to reiterate uh my department and
law enforcement support for this bill um
I'm more than happy to work with members
of the subcommittee or the full
committee on uh the nitty-gritty details
of the bill and any amendments that
should be made to uh particular sections
of the bill and um uh I'm a member of
the Attorney General's uh sexual assault
Advisory Board and we discuss bills like
this as well as part of that board so
I'm more than happy to to work with the
committee on any questions you may have
about uh different scenarios like you
were presenting to the attorney and give
a law enforcement perspective on that
but uh I do think that it is critical
that we that whatever uh bill is passed
that it has a uh uh culpable mental
state that is provable in these types of
cases uh because if the culpable mental
state is too high then uh I think the
bill loses its purpose entirely because
we just cannot use it so I would uh
certainly support a a negligent mental
state for these types of cases um and
with that I'm happy to take any
questions thank you um you mentioned you
were on the Attorney General's task
force and they looked at did they have a
chance to take a look at this proposed
legislation we have a meeting scheduled
at 1:00 this afternoon so I'll be uh
giving the board an update I'd be I'd be
pleased to hear what the feedback is
that you get um if you want to send it
to my email that would be good so I can
circulate it with the rest of the
committee members I would be happy to do
that sir thank you Chief any questions
for the
chief yes go
ahead um thank you for thaning my
question um did you see the or read the
sb23 the Senate bill regarding this as
well just curious uh I haven't had a
chance to revie all the details of that
bill I am aware of of that bill um and
uh I think uh this bill in front of you
has a framework that uh is very useful
from a law enforcement perspective um
these every child protection case is
very different and uh they call for very
different responses from our
multi-disciplinary team so some child
protection cases are really most
suitable for a uh uh civil child
protection resp response other cases
that are more egregious are really more
suitable for a law enforcement response
but what the public really expects of us
as a whole as a system is that uh we
work together and we have we address
each situation with the proper tools and
I think uh we are missing a very
important tool in terms of the law
enforcement response to these cases uh
that needs to be available to us and I
think this bill provides that thank you
Chief you see nothing else thank you
again thank you anyone else wishing to
forward good morning um I don't get to
visit the criminal justice committee
very often anymore uh my name is
attorney Lisa massio I am the associate
child advocate with the office of the
child advocate I used to show up here uh
when I worked for the Department of
Correction several years ago but in our
current role we do not specialize in
criminal law um so we tend to be in
children and family we did sign in last
week um on this bill unfortunately I
wasn't able to attend the hearing and
and I wasn't able to um connect with the
County attorneys we do have concerns
about this bill as written um the
stakeholders were not involved um from
the outset so we did sort of catch wind
of this a little bit late did not really
get brought into the conversation um as
I said when I signed in we just have
concerns as it's written um neglect
really is a term of art used in 169c it
is defined there um I think a lot of the
questions last week that I heard I did
watch on YouTube were very insightful
about sort of the breath and vagueness
of this language um and I did come today
to be able to point out to the committee
that um SP sp23 was filed we've actually
been working um with Lieutenant Nicholas
julus and the chiefs of police for quite
some time that language has actually
been floating around for a couple of
years um with a number of stakeholders
on that language because absolutely the
cases that were talked about last week
were horrific and should not happen
there are definite gaps in the system
that is why the office of child advocate
was created was because of cases like
those um I Heard uh Mr John de Joy's
testimony last week and we agree with
some of his points it is the child
protection system that um failed and and
had those gaps we are working on a bill
there too HB 553 was actually just heard
yesterday there are additional
definitions being proposed including um
very specifically under the definition
of neglect this idea of entrustment to
an inappropriate person in addition s
sp23 by enhancing endangering the
welfare of a child which I know you
mentioned um we think between those two
bills really these gaps can be filled
and we are
hesitant with the way this bill is
currently written to add an additional
crime um it may muddy the waters it
certainly is more difficult to reunify a
family or provide services when one
parent is incarcerated or taken out of
the home um we don't really support the
idea of a criminal law being used to
threaten people and force them to follow
a dcyf safety plan because as someone
asked last week the result of not
following a dcyf safety plan is having a
dcyf case filed and the end result of
that if you do not comply is that you
have your parental rights terminated so
that is a extreme outcome um we don't
know that adding an additional criminal
law will help that system work any
better we obviously support the
protection of children and want cases
like we heard about last week uh not to
happen that is the purpose of our office
um we're happy to work with folks um we
wish that we had kind of been involved
with the drafting of 257 earlier on um
we hate to come out against things that
are intended to help children because
this bill the intent truly is important
there are gaps in the system we want to
see them closed um we think that they
may be working within s sp23 and um we
hope that HB 553 has some of those
pieces too to fill those gaps in cases
like
that thank you um it seems to me though
our our statutes have a couple purposes
one purpose is is the deterrence that we
talked about um and another is
punishment and and so some of the things
we heard last week warrant punishment
absolutely so the two bills you've
talked about and really your office's
Bailey wig isn't necessarily in in the
criminal prosecution that punishment
aspect to the people that do these
things is it s sp23 is a criminal law
yes um that one it makes amendments to
the child endangerment statute to
enhance that um area and I think if this
committee finds gaps that may be able to
address in within that child
endangerment maybe flesh that out a
little bit more rather than adding this
new crime that is kind of Broad and kind
of vague may be more helpful um the
reason that we were involved with sb23
is because of that multi-disciplinary
team that the chief mentioned yeah often
a case particularly for abuse will
involve both child protection and um
criminal prosecution and it is typically
child endangerment and I did hear a
testimony last week that law has some
gaps too it's hard to prosecute the um
penalties were minimal so they weren't
really using it so SP sp23 is to enhance
criminal law and specifically the
penalties as well to make them felony
level in some cases which would make
them
um more prosecutable that there it's a
higher level penalty because exactly
those char that didn't happen in those
cases last week deserve to be felonies
um and that hadn't really existed so um
sb23 is Criminal which is why it was not
a bill the OCA was putting forth we
worked on it with Lieutenant George ulis
because he frequently works with us on
those multi-disciplinary teams he's a
juvenile detective um so yes criminal
law is not our Bailey Wick we let him
work on that with the chiefs of police
okay thank you um representative Murray
you have a
question well I was the along the same
lines with the punishment versus the
deterrence of this but um with SB 23 um
do you have thoughts on it looks like
there's already an adjustment to change
from purposefully endangering the
welfare to knowingly would you do you
have any thoughts on like lowering that
even even more like the uh yeah to
negligence I would defer to the the law
enforcement folks I I practiced in the
dcyf land in the Civil land I dabbled in
homicide prosecution at the AG's office
for a moment um but definitely I know
I'm Beth sergeant from the police Chiefs
Association is here I heard um Chief Lee
sorry um say that he was willing to work
together so I would absolutely defer to
them of you know what the men's Rea
needs to be obviously you know civil
it's preponderance of the evidence it's
a much lower standard but I would put
out there that if they're having trouble
charging and reaching that criminal
standard that is a reason why we are
also trying to bulk up that civil
standard because it ponderance of the
evidence is much lower to really fill
the gaps from both ends but I would I
would defer to them as to what they felt
the men's Rea needs to be from the cases
they've
seen thank you for sharing with us today
I do know the words men's Rea but that's
it's that's enough thank you I heard
that once on Law and Order myself anyone
anyone else wishing to speak to us who
has not yet done so seeing none thank
you very much and we're going to close
the subcommittee work session on this
bill like the last bill I think what
we'll do is we'll start off with a um
with a draft piece of legislation and
see what we can come together and in a
couple weeks we'll have a better feeling
on what the outcome of the Senate bill
will be and if if that bill um in anyway
addresses the concern that the County
attorneys had and if it doesn't we'll
you
e
that I'm opening the public hearing on
House Bill 500 establishing an enhanced
enforcement zones for motor vehicle
speed enforcement increasing the
penalties for speeding in those zones by
50% Etc I invite the prime sponsor
to introduce the bill is it me please
tell me something okay I know I'm one of
these
good morning Mr chairman good
morning well I guess it's not anymore
but good noon time to the criminal
justice committee for the record I'm
Representative Steve Pearson Rockingham
District 13 which encompasses the town
of
dairy what I bring before you today is
House Bill 500 establishing an enhanced
enforcement zone for motor vehicle speed
enforcement and increasing penalties
within those
zones I'll give you a little bit of my
background I've been a firefighter in
New Hampshire
for 24
years serving the overwhelming majority
Manchester I have spent time on actually
all three engine companies that I worked
for in my career in Manchester um had
responsibilities on the
interstates so what I'm bringing before
you here is something that is
potentially a way to address a
problem we have a significant speed
problem on our divided
highways just recently n Interstate 95
experienced over the course of several
Wednesdays we're quite not really not
sure why they were Wednesdays but some
horrific accidents fatalities we've had
a a very interesting and alarming number
of fatalities in the recent
and there's got to be some sort of a
mechanism here to to curb this now
law generally speaking does one of three
three things it either tells you to do
something it tells you not to do
something or it tells you how to do
something but law has to be
effective and
it through the I suppose wonderful work
of the Department of Transportation and
the automobile
industry we have the ability now to
travel at
speeds quite comfortably that we in the
entertained just driving up here
today in not very good weather
conditions and setting my cruise
control 17 people pass me above 75 for
well above 80 that's just one ride up
here and anybody that comes up here to
the State House via Interstate
93 I'm sure is well versed in what
they've experienced with their own two
eyes
so I took the the thought process here
and said
okay we need to increase enforcement
especially in these
areas so how do we do this and how do we
do this in a way where we're not
whacking the taxpayer necessarily with
the responsibility of an increased
enforcement presence now my
understanding is based on current law
speeding tickets are used the money
generated from speeding tickets are used
to fund the court
system what I am proposing is not
eliminating that in any way the courts
will still get
their revenue if you will their funding
from the generation of tickets but
within the en enforcement zones of of
these areas where we see the daily 100 m
hour vehicles
the enhancement of the find will go
towards a non-aps fund to be used by the
state police to pay for enhanced
enforcement because of course if you put
additional law enforcement on the road
cost
now we have to be realistic here
right everybody's had that moment
traveling down the road where they look
down at the speedometer and go whoa oh
hey you know I didn't realize I was
going that
fast so there's a there's got to be a
logical threshold is is to where you go
from hey I'm just kind of cruising
around and not really thinking about it
to you know you really have to be
thinking and be well aware of that you
are traveling in excess of posted speed
limits so 15 miles an hour seemed like a
good starting spot for
that that way it you know we're not
sitting here pulling people over for
over and six over and you know something
that's really just hey I was going down
a hill or you know I'm just cruising
along with the the guy that's in front
of me so that's the precipice of this
entire
concept it creates a non-aps and fund
which then pays for the overtime or
whatever we need the fuel the how
whatever the cost is associated with
having enhanced
enforcement and if you simply don't want
to fund it don't
speed it's just that simple I'd love to
see the fund have nothing in it because
that would mean we would have compliance
to our roads here I don't really want to
get into the breakdown of the license
plates for the people that fly by me at
excessive speed they happen to be mostly
red that's not a reflection on our
current State Legislative plate color um
but it is not certainly uh
solely the folks from other states that
are doing this we we bear responsibility
as well so this is kind of a New Concept
I'm not aware of this ever being
proposed or enacted before um but it is
you know a new new idea to to try to get
highways thank you repres for bringing
the spill to us have you had any um
contact or input from the Department of
Safety absolutely not okay
um I'm actually I have a bill that we'll
be hearing um that I actually filed with
regards to um speeding over 100 miles
per hour and the department of safety um
actually requested that we file it
because you are correct the accidents um
and the severity of them have increased
exponentially over the last few years so
there aware of it and they um they they
also find it to be um worthy of
legislation so I will um definitely when
we bring up the bill that I'm proposing
in your bill we'll look at the two of
those together absolutely sure um
questions for the
representative yes representative
s thank you for taking my question um
when I was growing up in the 50s and
6s uh if there was an automobile with
more than 300 horsepower
that was a high performance automobile
today you can buy from a dealer cars
with 600 800 or more
horsepower uh it's it's I don't know
where it stops but when you see these
cars that are going over a 100,000 or
100 miles an hour you wonder you know
maybe they're just cruising along with
their 800
horsepower whatever you know I saw the
other day on the news there was somebody
who was in a 35 mph Zone going over 100
m
hour I would very much chairman Roy
believe that yes it's it's horrendous
now this bill would not do anything to
that person am I correct cor yeah I
don't believe we have any 35 M zones on
our divided highways so no that's a that
would be a local ISS
too did you consider um a different
looking at the whole um the way that we
structure our speeding finds I know the
way they do it in the the state below us
that shall not be named um that I
believe for the first 10 miles an hour
over it's $50 and then it's I believe
it's $10 for every mile an hour
thereafter so it gets up into the four
five $600 range when you start going up
that many miles an hour uh did you look
at how our our speed finds are
structured no you know I what I what I
don't want to do is I don't want to at
least in my mind I don't want to have
the the guy that's looks down and he's
doing eight over I mean that that be $50
yeah I mean we have intent right I mean
f i I'd like to believe folks generally
want to do the right thing right and and
growing up in the 80s okay the pothole
era of New Hampshire um you know in in
vehicles of that time in and I can
certainly address and speak to I'm a hot
rod guy I have nine antiques but um so
you know there is a there is a
marketable difference between my 2017
Buick GS which is the same horsepower is
a 1986 Grand National right and the
Grand National was considered a a race
car so yes you know things have
progressed things have changed the the
Dodge um Hellcat is
800 show roughly 800 horsepower so I but
but again I don't want to get into the
like like you see in like small towns in
Missouri where they're writing your
speed and take it for four over I you
know I I just don't think that's the the
the intent and the idea behind this this
is for the folks when you get above 15
over you you know you're speeding you
know you're exceeding what is reasonable
and that's really where the enhanced
fruition represent Shar uh it would be
helpful if you if if you could um talk
to the Department of Safety and see what
they think about this just it I'm
uncomfortable I mean I like the idea um
uh in spite of the fact it might affect
my commute from Portsmouth um but it
would be useful to see what they think
if they're on board with this kind of
new structure well you know the purpose
of a public hearing is to bring forward
opinions and ideas of those affected by
legislation
and that might happen so um I would also
like to point out and I don't know how
this happened shame on me in the proof
reading process Interstate 89 was
supposed to be included in this and for
some reason it is not so um I'm not here
to uh let the fol on our Western area of
the state off the hook in this concept
um but that was an inadvertent
Omission okay um if we work on the
language we'll we'll reintroduce that
any further questions for the
representative
per yeah I'm thinking like 20 or 25
miles an hour over because like you say
in these cars if you're not paying
attention it's really easy to get up to
25 over and then look down and say oh
crap so that's where I'm at at 25
believe that's where I'm at well you
know representative PR um knowing that
your background is is similar in a lot
of ways to mine I I would believe that
but let's look at some of the math here
right so you get north of conquered the
speed limit goes to 70 right in theory
if you look at the Federal Department of
Transportation guidelines interstates
are designed at 75 mil an hour right at
that rate you'd be doing
95 before you hit that 95 you know
you're doing you're doing speeds at that
I at the 60 followup at the 65 M hour
speed limit 20 over probably 85 but I'm
thinking 80 okay we can have that
conversation in executive session um I
just want to go on the record and this
is all the fault of the electric car
people um the the the other ones came
out with that ridiculous car that has
ludicrous mode and it goes 170 mph that
would be the the um what is it the model
S um
um well chairman chairman Ry I believe
Ludicrous Speed was established um in
Space Balls but they did steal that so
um the other thing too to touch on that
you know that when you talk about today
in the the Automobiles and the
capabilities that we have today um
I'm trying to think of the non-ss sling
term to
describe Japanese manufactured
motorcycles
okay Kawasaki Yamahas those those
towards type of bikes there's nothing
closer in a in commercial purchasing
from a full-on race vehicle to a
purchasing vehicle than those type
of motorcycles like very little
difference so you know and we've had
I've lost a League actually on on 93 on
one of those U Back 20 25 years ago so
you know we we've experienced the
capabilities since the ninja came out
that that we have that problem what that
but a motor you know motorcyclists have
a tendency to in some ways when you
start to get to speeds like that they
kind of are steering their own destiny
this is now translated over into pickup
trucks and Buicks and sedans and Camry
and things that really back in the 80s
were running at about 85 horsepower and
would do 65 but you didn't you didn't
really like it if you got above 75 so
you know it's a matter of changing with
the times I suppose a little bit here
and the in the advancements and
Technology of both road construction and
automobile
manufacturing thank you anything
M as you went as you went about thinking
about penalty fees uh for the bill one
of the things that I'm interested in is
did you find any evidence along the way
that the changing or increasing the fine
would have a dramatic impact on behavior
and I'm thinking especially of that
person who buys the 800 horsepower car
probably can afford you know whatever
the increase in the fine is so are we
really changing Behavior with the fine
well I mean the the like I said the the
intent here is to provide a mechanism to
Inc increase
enforcement okay um you know I the state
police have a lot of struggles right now
in Staffing levels and um you know
thin using a mechanism of a of a non-aps
fund to
provide um more
opportunities for them
overwhelming goal of the
administration to bring law enforcement
back up to full strength there's it's
multifaceted but this is just another
you know not I don't think anybody's
going to join the state police so that
they can work overtime in a speed
enforcement Zone but I think it's just
something else that adds to the plate of
opportunities that they have um you know
we as we as we're in budget season and
we look at the financial implications of
everything that we do here this
particular mechanism is self-funded it's
not a budgetary impact thing and again
if they're not if we're not pulling
people over and we're not issuing
tickets for folks that are exceeding
these numbers then the fund has no money
and they but we we're well aware that
go
repr thank you Mr chair and thanks for
take my question um I am wondering about
um letting people know so you know
increasing awareness around it in the
first place so that you know I would
hope that people wouldn't um find out
when they get pulled over but rather be
deterred from speeding right so well um
you know as far as I know on the border
of of 93 we we don't have any signs that
say we don't really enforce speed limits
I mean we're not you know we're not
trying to advertise that hey you know
just kind of rock on here go to Five
lanes and Sal them let's go you know so
I
mean for I for us to advertise hey we
actually enforce our speed limits
I I'm not really sure how like well I
think uh what you know when you talk
about a an enhanced uh enforcement Zone
you know some of those would be if
there's construction going on or um for
one reason or another if there are um
there's a reason for people to need to
slow down so we do you know there's
signs that warn people of that I'm just
wondering if well I mean if they want to
put you know if the Department of
Transportation under our wonderful
French welcome sign wants to put you
know enhanced speed enforcement area
signs I mean that's up to perview the
Department of Transportation if they
want to advertise that or not I I I
don't know that saying hey please comply
with our law signs are necessary I
suppose well they I believe they already
do it with like airplanes they say are
in force and radar and force so I mean
some more some more vital stickers on a
piece of metal I don't think that we
would get involved in legislating that
though I think that they would determine
and frankly um I think the advertisement
would be in the media once we if we were
to enact such a law sure the Department
of Transportation the state police they
all have websites they all have Avenues
to disseminate information I mean okay
thank
chair and thank you to the members of
the committee uh my name is Matt amuchi
I am here representing the New Hampshire
State Police uh we are neutral um on
this bill and I just want to go over
some some statistics and some other
information that I have so uh first off
the state police is appreciative of the
fact that uh speed VI ators are viewed
as an issue throughout the state um we
recognize that there has been an
increase in speed violators throughout
the state over the past several years uh
from 2022 to 2024 there has been a 39%
increase in sumes issued for Speed
related offenses 15 plus miles an hour
over the posted speed limit in 65 plus M
hour zones and during that time same
time frame uh 39% increase in summons is
issued in um I'm sorry 36% increase in
summons is issued uh for 15 mes hour
over in 55 and less M hour zones so we
are seeing a drastic increase in
violators but we're trying to address it
as best we can with um citations
issued um even with the increased number
of citations being issued by State
Police over the past three years there's
been little change to driving
behavior if the intent of this bill is
to act as a deter by increasing fines it
could be accomplished by increasing the
uniform fine schedule for 55 60 65 70 M
hour
zones um by
50% did you um and I don't want to
interrupt but since you brought it up
did you hear the question I asked with
regard to the structure of how we we
structure our speeding fines versus how
mass does it I did what do you what are
your thoughts on that do you think our
structure the way it's set up is is the
best or do you think we we should look
at changing that I think it could be
Revisited we haven't I don't believe
adjusted our fines in number of years
and A lot's changed over the last five
um the uniform fine schedule hasn't been
anyways
um those funds could still be allocated
as the committee deems um appropriate
I think a more effective um change to
driving
behavior um it may be beneficial to look
at crash data and speed data um on our
highways and strategically post enhanced
enforcement zones as you had previously
stated um those warning signs could read
something to the effect of high crash
area ahead um speeding strictly enforced
fines increased by 50% I do think that
education
um warnings will help deter um fines
also are used as a deterrent but I think
in this case specifically on our
highways looking at data as it relates
to crashes and speed um and posting
those areas like you do with
construction zones may be
effective
um and this bill was not proposed by the
state police we're neutral on where the
enhanced speed zone fund is appropriated
um whether it's to the Department of
Safety the general fund or otherwise um
I appreciate the Innovative thinking as
to how some of these funds could be
utilized to um support the initiative of
of speeding uh violators uh so with that
I'll be glad to try to answer any
questions thank you Captain um could you
explain to the committee how it works
with regard to warnings um specifically
if you were operating one of these zones
and um the lodg just came into effect I
I assume that there would be some type
of directive for a little bit of a
period of um warning
people when you give someone a warning
and then that person's pulled over two
weeks later by another Trooper what do
they see you could see their motor
vehicle history
um in in our in-house system yeah local
agencies many of them use a different
system they can see local history to
local history we're on a different
system than many agencies um so we can't
always see if they were warned in a a
local town or city um
necessarily but what does the warning
say does it say warning for speeding
correct so you'll know what they were
warned for you know what they're warned
for um in the zone or whatever the
infraction was but not necessarily how
fast they were
going um one other question I had is
regarding insurance Insurance in New
Hampshire we don't require all drivers
to have
insurance one of the big deterrents um
in my mind is you get a speeding ticket
your insurance goes up
significantly if you're not required to
have insurance that doesn't really
impact you um at what point are you
required to get insurance in New
Hampshire is it only after an accident
where you're at fall or is it can it
also be for
violations I know for for accidents
you're required to to have insurance um
I'm not sure if you hit x amount of
points if you're required to I'm not
aware of that okay thank you I think
that's something to look at because I
know for me I would be the ticket would
be painful but what would be devastating
is the insurance um increase over the
next five years um which is exponential
so if someone doesn't have insurance
doesn't matter to them they pay the
ticket and they move on so thank you um
any other questions for Captain yes
representative
Newman yeah I have a question for
question on one of the things that the
chair said about um speed check by
aircraft do you have any data or
anecdotal information
on how whether that's a deterrent or you
find that out as a deterrent it seems to
me that when I think some of the
aircraft's up there and I don't know
whether he there or not it may be
because they used to do air traffic
stuff that I say this is if I were
intending to go faster I would slow down
yes sir what do you think about that yes
sir thank you for the question um yes
our our aircraft is extremely effective
um those signs that you see are
typically warning operators once they've
traveled through what we're looking at
to warn you that there there are going
to be officers on the side of the road
um that's not warning you that to slow
down at that point it's it's warning you
that there's going to be several
Troopers ahead of you that have already
stopped vehicles but you've already
traveled through that zone you know
those four zones that we're we're
looking at
um so yes we're we're warning there is a
deterrent we're trying to slow operators
down and have them move over because
we're going to be stopped on the side of
point I just think that it may may be a
deterrent when you're not even around
you know that's anyway but I'll go on to
my question
um you you mentioned that an accident
causes an increase in insurance I'm I'm
just curious how that works I know that
trying to get a law to pass Insurance
the insurance companies don't like that
because they don't want it to be
mandatory especially a minimum because
they don't make any money do you have
any um just explain to me why what what
happens after an accident so from my
understanding is once you're involved in
an accident in the state you're then
required to have insurance um whether it
in increases that's up to the insurance
company um we do get complaints often
from um those sou of us because of
because of just that their insurance is
going to go up for for five years
hundreds of dollars per year they're not
concerned with a $500 ticket they're
concerned with the fact it's going to
cost them $3,000 over the next five
years because of um the increase to
answer your previous question there are
states that have um a fixed signs along
the highway saying that the that the
highway is monitored by aircraft and
those stay up year round whether there's
aircraft or not we just have the the
temporary ones while we're out enforcing
these that um and that's more to warn
operators that ahead of you you're going
to have multiple Cruisers and we do see
Vehicles slow down at that point move
over um because we don't want to have
accidents or get struck by by passing
motorists we might need the permanent
sir representative new
new thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking my question um I H as you know
the mom of um two kids who are one just
got his license and the other one is
coming up um keenly aware um that we
have um a serious issue with youth um
accidents and and even deaths and things
like that and so hearing a whole lot
about that generally speaking what I've
heard is that it is mostly distracted
driving or I'm just curious if if you
have any um uh if you have any data or
anything like that to say that speed
might be a part of that or have you seen
that um speed is a part of the um youth
I'm sorry my trying to say it um part of
um the reason why we are having so many
um accidents with the youth I'm sorry
you get what I'm saying thank you for
the question yes um as it relates to our
fatalities um distracted driving
impaired driving speed those are the
three things that we see in nearly every
fatality there are instances where it's
medical related um somebody has a
seizure while they're driving but the
vast majority um that we are seeing it's
impairment it's distracted driving and
speed related and that's across the
representative
lell thank you for taking my question uh
I'm a great believer in
technology um and I'm just wondering uh
do you folks um like for instance where
the hooks at tolls are all right there
are cameras there and uh there's ways of
keeping track of um cars if we had
another set of just sensors
you know north of that maybe 10 miles
and if we could keep track of how much
time it took a a vehicle to get between
that 10 Mile Stretch and if they
exceeded a certain amount could we
summarily pull these folks over is is
there a way that you're looking at
technology to act as a
deterrent uh great question um not that
I'm aware of I mean there's a lot of
Technology that's out there you see the
red light cameras in other states um you
see you know speed obviously when you go
through tolls it does track speeds
um it it's a great question um I don't
have a an answer on on that particular
question as far as what technology is is
being used we do um test license uh
readers but those are more for like
stolen vehicles and and things like that
um there's there's a lot of Technology
out there and it continues to grow how
can we effectively utilize that that
the citizens of the state are
comfortable
with I'm not sure thank you I can tell
you that stoplight cameras are not one
of them representative
Murray thank you Mr chair um just uh to
follow up on that so to clarify do we
ever issue like male tickets to People
based on like enforcement radar whatever
that we may have picked up or is it
really just all about like the inperson
on the side of the road enforcement is
that like the only Avenue yeah it's it's
in person there are times where you get
mailed a ticket for one reason or
another um my printer is not working I
can certify mail you a ticket but I have
to identify who you are um it's unlike
Easy Pass where if you violate it the
operator of that vehicle is going to
receive a Cit
uh or fees in the mail we don't do that
as far as uh speed is
related what about after accidents
sometimes do you mail citations after an
complete
um maybe not that that I'm not sure I
mean there's times where we certainly
charge them yeah with different things I
don't know if we would just mail them a
ticket it would probably be a must
appear they'd be issued a court date uh
and then a complaint would come with
that um I'm not sure that they would
just be sent a citation in the mail uh
upon the completion of a
investigation my last question with
regard to um speeding and arrest we see
a lot of times in the in the media where
someone um usually those motorcyclists
uh are going a certain amount over the
speed limit and they end up being
arrested for what is the charge they use
to to arrest a a speeding motorist yes
sir um Reckless operation so when the
when the um law was changed that allowed
for if you're traveling 100 miles an
hour or more it becomes a reckless
operation that is a arrestable offense
and does the State Police have a policy
as far as um shall arrest or is it
really still up to the offic of
discretion still up to discretion good
okay thank you
rep yeah um if people when people go
through the tolls you have a plate and
you Can you capture the speed and if you
capture a speed that's
outrageous can can they is there a law
can they sent a violation of some nature
just
curious um thank you for the question um
that's all tracked by Easy Pass and it's
a separate entity from us um they don't
share any of the information with us and
anytime that we try to obtain it we have
to do a search warrant to get those
records thank you
Sher three three types of deterrence
that I see in this circumstance uh I'm
I'm not a big fan of fines as a
deterrent it's just a Flatout punishment
I I think most people
don't um but in with
fines increase in insurance loss of
license those three are the classic
deterrence how are could you give me
your judgment as to the effectiveness of
deterrent um yeah they they would all be
viewed as deterrent based on the person
you know if if people have the funds
then the the monetary loss that they
that they face um may not be as
impactful
um you know the loss of license that may
be more impactful because they're trying
to get to work they work for a
high-paying job hypothetically if
they're um so I I think I think
deterrents are important um I think
education is important I agree that the
vast majority of of the people on our
roadways are law abiding citizens that
want to do the right thing um have
things been you know have we seen an
increase in in speed over the years yes
um um and that's why bills like this are
are good to to take a look at uh work
with in an attempt to help combat and
get um all operators on our roads um
environment thank you for taking our
questions today thank you thank you sir
is there anyone else wishing to testify
on House Bill 500 who has not done so
seeing none I hereby closed public
hearing we will reopen at 1:00 block um
Republican members if you could just all
stay here we're going to reconvene in
about 10 minutes to do our executive
answer your question in theory if they
track when you pass through the bed for
tools and when you pass through the
hooks at tools it's a given distance
you
e
afternoon I'm uh opening the public
hearing on House Bill
592 and I invite the sponsor to come
forward am I doing that is it no never
mind sorry
it's: yeah I thought it was later than
it was I I want to go home so I'm trying
to move um open house the public hearing
for House Bill
245 establishing the speed enforcement
and awareness fund providing grants for
mpal law enforcement for Speed
enforcement and speed awareness I invite
the prime sponsor to introduce the
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Keith adman I represent Hillsboro
District 42 which is Mount Mount Vernon
lineboro and New Boston where I
live so I'm introducing House Bill
245 to the committee it would establish
a speed enforcement and awareness fund
and provide grants to Municipal law
enforcement for Speed
enforcement and speed awareness traffic
equipment so just a high level overview
of the
bill uh this came about in New Boston
this idea um and the chair of our select
board will be coming behind me and
explain more Mr Bill
mcfaden uh but the idea is we have a
small town we're kind of on the way to
other
places and we have uh you know tourists
people coming through our town and we
have to enforce uh traffic
laws uh when a ticket is written of
course it goes to the general fund and a
couple other
funds um and because you know taxes are
tight uh we we could use a little more
uh speed enforcement equip
so things like radar guns and signs and
things like that and so the idea is to
direct a small portion of ticket fees to
a fund that municipalities around the
state can apply for a grant from and
that Grant can only be used for a a
specific list of things that's mentioned
in the bill and that way it you know
would spread some of the costs around
and make our our streets safer
across the state uh that's that's the
gist of my testimony happy to answer any
questions thank you for bringing us the
spill representative um some people I'm
sure are going to argue that this may
create a per perverse incentive for
police to write more tickets so that
they can generate more money for more
equipment um what would be your response
to that yeah so certainly we wouldn't
want to have the ticket written locally
go to the local Department because that
would be a perverse incentive so this
doesn't raise or lower fees the fees
would still stay the same just a small
portion would go to a a pool at the
state level um so it be a trickle from
all the towns would go into this pool
and then the the Departments that might
be short of equipment to enforce traffic
uh in their location could apply for a
grant uh it would be a needs-based
program uh and the fund would be
distributed to the the towns that need
it the most so I think there's enough of
a disconnect between yeah the ticket
itself and that fund being dispersed
that it would not present a perverse
incentive yeah it sounds like you have a
few firewalls in there you've got the
the first one where it's not going
directly to the town then it's they have
to apply for it they're not even sure if
they're going to get it so that much
distance would make it very difficult to
Target a specific piece of equipment and
say we're going to get this this year
right oh thank you questions
represent
PR I see on your list you have automated
speed
cameras really don't would you be
willing to get rid of that because I
think that's a slippery slope to go down
yeah thank you for the question um so as
is the custom it's the committee's bill
so we're relying on your judgment on how
to improve the bill and I would
certainly be open to that suggestion
thank
you thank you any further questions
representative
Sher I'm I'm just looking at the bill
now how is it determined how much goes
to this uh non-aps fund is there's a
it's on the last page of the bill it's
uh section two article uh section four
Roman number four and so what it's doing
is taking the
66% that the treasurer would deposit
into the general fund and it's reducing
that by an amount and it's it's an
arbitrary number so that could be
adjusted to um and that
8.3% would go to this new fund got it
thank
you see no further questions thank you
you the chair calls um Captain amui
thank you Mr chair and committee
members um my name is Matt amuchi within
Hampshire State Police um we're neutral
on this bill as well um this bill would
align with the mission of the office of
Highway Safety in many ways and I kind
of just want to go over what the mission
of the office of Highway Safety is um
more for educational purposes than
anything else so the office of Highway
Safety is responsible for developing
implementing effective strategies to
reduce the state's traffic related
injuries and fatality rates these
strategies may take the form of
Standalone projects activities Andor
comprehensive long-term programs both
traditional and Innovative strategies
are encouraged and utilized to support
the office of Highway Safety goals they
do um they do this as a pass through
entity for program funding received from
the national highway traffic safety
administration also known as Nitsa
um for things that include uh speed
enforcement and Equipment amongst other
uh things like impaired driving
enforcement and Equipment distracted
driving enforcement occupant protection
enforcement pedestrian bicycle
enforcement as well as media and
messaging and education Outreach
programs so the office of Highway Safety
is responsible for administration of the
Federal Highway Safety funds and for
facilitating the highway safety programs
supported by these funds
uh their funding is in the form of um
reimbursement to the subrecipient under
Grant uh agreements indor um
contacts the only item in this bill that
Nitsa doesn't fund um would be the use
of the automated speed cameras except in
school and work Zone um that's the only
place that
Nitsa um would allow for those funds to
to be
utilized
um I can say that the the local agencies
in the state police are not utilizing
all of the funds that have been
allocated um mostly due to to Staffing
um I think that when New Hampshire law
enforcement agencies are better staffed
it would be beneficial to have um
additional State funding available uh
through Innovative strategies such as
this in this bill so with that there's
any
questions just uh if I could recap so
the Nitsa kind of does this already on a
separate track um but when the
Departments get um proper Staffing and
operating on all cylinders there's
definitely room for additional funding
that this would is that pretty much what
you said yes sir so essentially what's
proposed um is what Nitsa does on the
federal level with federal grants that
are distributed through the office of
Highway Safety to both state and local
agencies um at this time okay um is it
possible that there there isn't enough
funding available there I'm I'm trying
to figure out why why what brought the
need for this bill if there was already
this funding
there that I'm not sure um I can tell
you that there's plenty of funds
available um over the last three years I
have data over the last three years um
we haven't exceeded um close to the
funding that is available so whether uh
an application was applied for um by the
agency that's requesting this or or
seems that this is a problem uh I would
encourage them to reach out to the
office of Highway Safety to see what
what funds are available um does the
office of Highway Safety um operate
proactively reaching out letting
departments know there's money available
and things like that that I don't know
okay all right thank you see you no
further questions thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else wishing
to testify on this bill who has not done
so seeing none I hear
seat okay Mr mcfaden go ahead
good afternoon Mr chairman good
afternoon ladies and gentlemen of the
committee my name is Bill mcfaden I am
the chair of the select Board of New
Boston and I've reached out to my
representative to introduce this bill
this started with a general discussion
with one of the officers on duty while
we were having our voting last November
uh we just started to talk about
speeding we have a we have a large
speeding problem in the town of New
Boston I travel I commute from New
Boston to Hudson daily and I see it in
every municip spity I driveth through uh
people are just they're crazy out there
so it was just a general discussion and
I started to talk talk with the officer
about that and he said he has the tools
we have radar but we don't have lidar
which is laser uh and he's like it's
just it's too costly I'm like okay so
what can we do and I'm speaking not just
on behalf of New Boston but other
smaller municipalities where budgets are
tight um you know we don't have a large
commercial base in town so it's it's
residents that are that are footing the
bill and whenever uh police departments
try to add add uh items to their budget
everybody has you know they they get all
worked up so I started to think about
what about a a possible grant program uh
where some of the monies from uh traffic
tickets can go into a grant and
municipalities can go to this pool and
apply for apply for monies for equipment
um I spoke with my chief my chief of
police in town he thought it was a great
idea we're not we're not a poor town but
we're not certainly not a um we have no
commercial base in town so again it goes
back to the the funding of this so we
started to talk about what could it be
used for light our guns uh digital speed
control devices because I can tell you
as as a driver when I see those speed
controls it always makes my eyes go
right down to my speedometer and if I
see them just a few miles over it I will
slow down those those devices do work um
and by that you're talking about those
portable signs the portable or or
trailer the trailer ones as well uh and
just it's simple things like that I
think that could help uh around the
state um to try to get traffic to slow
down because it is just it really is out
of control right now and I'm just trying
to do my part to see what we can do to
try to curtail
this and we appreciate it thank you um
you heard the earlier testimony
regarding Nitsa the National Highway uh
safety have you or your town applied for
any grants to them that I do not know
but I made a note and I am certainly
going to investigate that okay if you if
you could when you talk to your Chief
and you get feedback on that could you
ask him to pass it on or you pass it on
to your representative so we could get
it back here absolutely do I appreciate
it any questions from the
committee I I would assume that a lot of
your speeding problems are caused by
those those um strange space force
people that are stationed in New Boston
I think have you seen a lot of so so
some of there and a lot of the uh skiers
that go to um you know this we have Pats
Peak right nearby and we have over in
Frances town we have the scary too we
see a lot of out of state plates okay
that that's just are do you do you
provide it or does your Police
Department provide any security or work
in tandem with the base security yes we
do and do you receive any funding back
from the feds to that we do we actually
just had a k9 program established um and
they're funding that they're funding
that so they're very good partner with
the community it's good to hear great
thank you all right uh see you no
further questions thank you for coming
today thank you very much you're welcome
now is there anyone else wish to testify
who's not testified in a spill seeing N
I hereby close the public hearing we
2:00
e
I'm hereby opening the public hearing on
House Bill 592 and invite the sponsor to
Bill thank you Mr chairman um Mr
chairman for the my name is
representative rosbury I represent the
towns of
uh gtown and wear in Hillsboro 39 I'm
here for the purpose of introduction for
House Bill
592 which is about uh magistrates and
bail reform um I don't need to elaborate
to this body The Saga that has been bail
reform um but I do think we may be
finally approaching hopefully the Final
Chapter so as as we know PR bail has
been basically an adamant failure um we
just had an incident where an officer
was shot uh in an altercation with
somebody who should have been in jail um
one of my former constituents as you
know was stabbed to death by a person
who was out on double cashless bail um
and the the stories have become Stranger
Than Fiction but I do think with the
changes in conquered um in the in the
halls of legislature um that we do
finally have something that will put an
end to this so so I have distributed to
the committee an amendment that I worked
with the governor aot's office on um and
2025-the
um because I felt that the statement
needed to be made that the system
doesn't work but I also live in the
reality that we may never see full
appeal so what this bill does in a
nutshell and I'll let people behind me
who are well more versed than it and can
answer your questions answer those
questions but what what it does as
nutshell is it takes what was working
the small parts of PR bail that were
working um and it keeps it in place um
but it gets rid of kind of the extreme
examples of just letting people go it it
ends the revolving dorm so it has things
in there like you're not going to get PR
Bal if you're arrested while already out
on bail if you violate a bond condition
those sort of things it takes it from
the basically automatic default to a you
need to prove that you qualify for it so
I know that this is going to be a long
hearing there's many members of the law
enforcement he Community hopefully in
support of this um and I'm going to let
the governor's office if the chair will
indulge me let the governor's office and
their representative come up and explain
what's in the contents of this amendment
spill the chair calls miles mat from the
governor's
office good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee uh and with
your Indulgence Mr chair um if we could
also invite uh Tom valard is's the
director of the division of public
protection and the Department of Justice
uh up to testify with me if that's
amendable to the that would be fine as
long as you both filled out a pin card
please members of the committee the
amendment that you have before you uh is
designed to protect our communities
protect law enforcement and it is
incorporating Lessons Learned uh in the
bail reform efforts of the past seven in
eight years and as representative Barry
indicated it's designed to stop a
revolving door whereby U repeat
offenders are exposed to the community
uh and committing crimes uh again and
it's tailored to that uh to that
population the governor supports this
this amendment it should be no surprise
to you that the the governor uh spoke to
a number of people about bail reform on
the campaign Trail uh that she heard
from many citizens across our state that
she has heard from law enforcement with
her background has um an intimate
knowledge of this subject area and that
this is an important issue uh to her to
address and is supportive of this
amendment and this effort uh to revise
current law with the lessons that have
been learned um in our past number of
years uh the the primary focus is to
ensure protection U for our communities
for victims uh uh and for our Law
Enforcement Officers by taking a common
sense approach that focuses on repeat
offenders by those who have previously
committed offenses while on bail who
have violated bail conditions or have
failed to appear for their Court
appearances so some of the lessons
learned from um our our past efforts at
at bail reform is that current law is
not adequately protecting our
communities or law enforcement for that
subset of individuals who repeatedly
flout the
law uh you may be familiar with the
governor's right along uh with a police
officer who had his finger noded to the
Bone by an individual who uh was
dangerous to others dangerous to the
community as was just mentioned there
was a Bedford officer who was shot
during a skirmish with an individual who
had numerous failures to appear
including on a charge of possession of a
dangerous
weapon uh and under the features of our
current system technically he was uh not
detained because he hadn't um hit the
required number of failures to appear in
the short enough time frame uh so he was
out and he seriously injured a police
officer the current uh law that has a a
three strikes rule for failures to
appear is a permission slip to continue
to ignore court orders and obligations
to be responsive and to appear uh in our
justice system and current law prohibits
judges from ordering detention where
there's probable cause to believe that a
person will be dangerous to themselves
to others or to the community so the
amendment before the committee takes a
common sense approach of trying to close
those loopholes to appropriately craft
the standard the threshold the mechanism
such that a judge can protect the
community protect Law Enforcement
Officers protect individuals who pose a
danger to themselves or who have a
demonstrated history of failing to
comply with conditions imposed upon them
and that's really to stop the re
revolving door that we've heard about
and that we
see uh current law sometimes allows an
offender even where there is probable
cause to believe that they pose a danger
to themselves another or to the
community or has a history of violating
bail conditions either by ignoring bail
conditions failing to appear or
committing new offenses back on the
street
and uh you may hear from our Law
Enforcement Officers where they may have
an individual such as that and that
individual may be released back to the
street before the police have even been
able to finish and file their police
reports that's not a system that's
working that's a system that should be
addressed in order to prohibit that
outcome this amendment judges have the
discretion to be able to look in those
circumstances and keep those individuals
detained they have judges have
discretion one of the lessons learned to
be able to look at the financial
conditions of an individual and to take
those account such that the financial
conditions alone are not going to have
someone
detained but where there is evidence
indicating that there is a danger or
history of of non-compliance Judges will
have that authority to detain those
individuals so listen to our law
enforcement listen to our
communities listen to
those experiences and the empirical
evidence that suggest that we need to be
tailoring our approach to this subset of
of individuals this is a common sense
bail reform that will improve our system
protect our communities protect our law
enforcement and it's not just anecdotal
there is empirical evidence that focuses
and directs us to establishing a
mechanism to focusing on this set of
individuals um who are high use or
repeat offenders so with that and to
speak to that point would like to hand
off to uh Tom valard the director of the
division of public protection in the
Department of Justice thank you Attorney
Madison thank you ladies and gentlemen
it's a pleasure to be here it's been a
long seven years I have been part of
bail reform discussion since their
Inception in 2018 um and I think it's
important for me to
recognize the real work and effort that
many of you in this room have put into
improving the situation both for people
accused of crimes as well as for our
communities I want to emphasize uh
however that there is another step that
can be taken and I believe that this
Governor's Bill addresses that
specifically it has to do um as been
said by the rep uh representative who's
sponsoring this amendment as well as
Attorney Madison that term we keep using
revolving door I don't particularly like
it we are talking about human beings who
may be having struggles but the fact of
the matter is they are coming in and out
of the criminal justice system with
great rapidity
in fact uh our
state sanctioned the uh Center uh
Justice Center Council of state
governments to look at that very issue
and for a number of years they have one
of the findings that they made uh in
this report which I'm happy to leave
with the with the committee is that this
the stories that you've heard not just
here today but over the years which have
been sort of chocked up to being just
random anecdotes are not that at all
these are empirical studies that show
there is a small percentage of the
population who has been turned out again
and again and again they happen to be a
very complicated subset of the
population the typically up to 70 plus
percent have co-occurring issues but
these are folks who are committing not
violent crimes they're committing
property crimes low-level crimes and
continuously getting re-bailed
if you take a look at this report you're
going to see the millions and millions
of dollars that that cost the state of
New Hampshire just in
Medicaid not to mention the cost of just
the constant re bookings not to mention
the stories that you'll hear probably
from my law enforcement colleagues here
about the frustration of seeing the same
people bailed and then constantly re
bailed and um much like you I was an
elected official for 16 years I had
constituents calling me asking me as a
county attorney why was this person just
bailed and they're back out and they
broke into my store I'm a small business
owner I can't afford this kind of
situation how can this possibly happen
when the courts of New Hampshire have
bailed this
person this bill is designed to look at
that very issue it keeps so many of the
other improvements that we've all talked
about over the last seven years and have
collaborated on but when you look at the
three categories uh of what judges will
be directed to look at it really gets to
the heart of who is likely to appear in
that subsequent
hearing who is likely to remain safe in
the community and keep us safe and also
balancing how many people can we safely
keep in the community we know we can do
that and that's why this is not a repeal
of uh the uh PR system we know that that
can safely be done this bill strikes a
really good balance to finally go after
that subset that has been identified by
an outside agency as being a real
problem for the courts uh and will treat
them fairly but will identify them in
such a way as we can stop or put a
stopper if you will in that revolving
door that's the exciting aspect of this
bill and look forward to the further
discussion and for your consideration of
it thank you gentlemen um and I'd like
to extend thank you to you Mr Val for
recognizing the work that we did put
into this um many many hours last year
to come up with a compromise Bill to um
get some progress forward and I look
forward to looking at this and and
making further progress as well um I
would also like to say that we I I'm
intending to to make a um a subcommittee
um in probably take about a week or so
and I'd like both of you if you were
available to work with us and with the
court it's my understanding that this
this wasn't socialized with the court
first before it was submitted to us and
they may have some concerns um not with
regard to um the issues of who should
and should not be held more about
logistic type things so I think that
that shouldn't be a problem for us to
overcome and and get a good piece of
legislation out um any questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you both for
today the chair calls um The Honorable
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Jay Rue mayor of Manchester I also
want to extend my thanks to this
committee being an elected official
myself I recognize how difficult it can
be when you're working through uh
difficult nature uh difficult topics
like this so I appreciate all the work
that the previous legislature and
Governor did to get us to this point
today I also want to take a moment to
thank uh Chief Maher and assistant Chief
Louie who came up today from Manchester
also to show their support uh for this
effort to further work on PR
bale as mayor my most important job is
to keep the city safe and the safety of
our city is absolutely nonnegotiable and
the the simple truth is that when people
are Bad actors when they are engaging in
uh illegal activities they need to be
held accountable for their actions I
would give uh one example um in my past
life I do believe that the criminal
justice system can be rehabilitative and
I do think that there are opportunities
to take an individual who may be going
on a bad path and reorient them and I
would use my own example in my own life
as testimony to that fact I've been very
open about the fact that I've been in
recovery for 14 years and but for uh my
Association at the time with the
criminal justice system I don't know
that I would be sitting in this these
seats so I think this part is twofold
one there are Bad actors on the streets
that have no place being on the streets
of the city of Manchester or
municipalities in the state of New
Hampshire additionally I do think that
there are opportunities to take an
individual and help make them a better
person and a a good uh productive member
of society the bottom line though is
that if you are arrested for committing
a violent crime particularly if you are
out on bail you have no place on the
streets of the city of Manchester other
municipalities in our state and I think
we had talked a little bit about this
already but the the challenge that we
run into Manchester is the the violent
and the repeat offenders specifically so
in speaking with our Police Department I
just want to give a couple quick
examples of uh what we experience uh in
the city of Manchester so these
following examples highlight this
problem so individuals who were arrested
for serious crimes released on PR bail
only to be rearrested for the following
crimes murder stalking stabbing assault
and armed robbery I I appreciate the the
opposing argument on this that we do not
want to be locking up individuals for uh
Petty crimes or or things that they're
doing to subsist these are not those
kinds of crimes and this is what we're
dealing with in the city of Manchester
and this isn't just anecdotal we have
strong numbers uh to back this up and
our police department has done an
extraordinary job at being able to
compile this data to make I think a
compelling argument in favor of uh
further reforming bail in 20124 there
were
2,971 adults arrested in the city of
Manchester these individual ual
accounted for
4,551 arrests the gentleman before me
spoke about this that is a a smaller
subset of the population that is
committing an egregious amount of crimes
in the city of Manchester these numbers
don't add up because 27% of them were
arrested more than once so of the
2971 individuals arrested 715 or 24% of
them were out on bail at the time of
that arrest so this creates multiple
problems number one obviously for our
city who is continuing to experience or
become victims of these crimes but also
for our Police Department you know not
unlike other departments across the
state we have we we roughly float around
20 vacancies so we have fewer cops and
we're asking them to do more with less
because they're continuing to have to
arrest the same individuals over and
over again this is not sustainable we
cannot continue down this path here in
the city of
Manchester there could be nothing so
transformative for our city than to
remove nearly 1,000 criminals from the
streets of
Manchester so in addition to the change
in the city this would have a dramatic
impact on law law enforcement as I I
spoke to that the morale obviously in
the the city of Manchester is high they
are always going to do their jobs but
this certainly creates a barrier for
them and it makes it more difficult to
do the jobs that they were trained and
assigned to do uh so I I really
appreciate the opportunity to be here
today I I truly appreciate sincerely
appreciate the work that this committee
does um I again I recognize how
difficult uh that the nature of your
jobs are but I I I would really
encourage you all to continue down this
path let's find something that we can
work with again there would be nothing
so transformative for the city of
Manchester than having something like
this uh take effect where we could
potentially remove a thousand criminals
from our streets so thank you so
much thank you Mr Mayor see you no
questions from the committee thank you
thank you
the chair calls attorney Aon krian from
Court good afternoon members of the
committee uh eron krian general counsel
for the judicial branch and surely for
those of you that are returning uh I'm a
familiar face uh and we we saw a lot of
each other when we were discussing uh
bail last year and I appreciate so much
the opportunity to work with you uh as
you know uh there were a number of
changes that the judicial branch made in
order to effectuate the will of the
legislature as as uh expressed in HB 318
one of those was the hiring of three
judicial officers um who quit their jobs
became magistrates and and have very
extensive backgrounds as police officers
as defense attorneys and as prosecutors
um that that prepared them well uh
underwent extensive training as well um
I see this amendment uh and I I think
there are many positive changes in the
amendment but I believe that this
preserves a portion of the underlying
bill which um in relatively short order
abolishes those positions uh what I
might suggest to you is that uh those
they were appointed to 5e terms you may
wish to Sunset the position at the end
of the terms as opposed to immediate
abolition um in recognition that uh
these judicial officers did accept that
position for the purpose of implementing
your your design your will um they are
public servants um or just have mercy on
me as someone who defends the branch
from employment actions um but uh that
is something that I put to your
consideration even if you determine that
that's not something you do want to
preserve whether you would at least like
to consider sun setting at the end of
their current term which is a five-year
term um the magistrates although they
are highly qualified and highly trained
cost about half as much as a full-time
judge I think it's actually less than
half um and they perform many many
routine functions that up judges time
and push out calendars uh for other
cases um the Circuit Court retook the
initial proceedings relating to felonies
relatively recently that that came with
no additional staff or resources the the
help of the magistrates in processing
many of those preliminary hearings is is
very valuable in defraying costs for the
court and moving some of those
proceedings along uh so I put that to
your consideration is of course always
the determination of the legislature um
the way to move forward but I I at least
want to raise
those questions for your
consideration um in my first review of
the original uh draft of this bill um I
haven't had an opportunity to work with
my friends and colleagues in the
executive branch on it but I look
forward to doing that I did note that
there were some potentially um drafting
errors um for example I saw that
detention was accidentally eliminated as
an option on first appearance and that
the assumption that a victim would not
have to testify in person was um was
accidentally eliminated I I I assume
that those were accidents and I see that
those have been correct in this version
I haven't had a chance to review it
extensively but there are a couple
relatively logistical minor issues that
uh may be worthy of the legislator's
consideration for example uh another
section of this bill which doesn't
appear in this amendment um abolishes a
provision that times first hearings that
uh typically saves a lot of time in the
morning docket and I'd love to speak
with the sponsors about what their um
what their legislative intention is in
doing that and see if there would be a
way to effeti it that would not require
um morning hearings to all be stalled
while we're waiting for attorneys which
is the original reason that the
legislature had passed that change um so
there are a few logistical matters but
of course if those of you that worked
with me last year know that the the
judicial branch certainly understands
that we implement the laws that you
write the policy determination is yours
we will work with you on whatever it is
that you determine is best to do uh
there are no two states that have
identical bail laws there is a very wide
range of policy solutions that the
judicial bran Branch can Implement um
and we're very very happy to work with
you to see that we can Implement your
design and your policy
attention thank you um I can speaking
for this committee as a part of the
legislature it's important for us that
when we craft legislation that the
people that we ask to do are able to
carry it out so that's why I think it's
very important that we get together with
the court and the the sponsors and make
sure that we can it's actually doable
and we do it right the first time
because I I swear I'm not going to deal
with bail again next year this is it um
having said that any questions regarding
the
court seeing none thank you for coming
today meliss DAV the chair calls Melissa
Davis
still a novice um good afternoon thank
you for the opportunity to speak my name
is Melissa Davis I'm here on behalf of
the New Hampshire Association of
criminal defense lawyers I'm currently
uh the director of the criminal Practice
Clinic at UNH law prior to joining UNH
law uh I was a public defender in New
Hampshire for 15 years so I've been a
criminal defense practitioner for 20
years I'm not here on behalf of the
University of New Hampshire on behalf of
I'm here on behalf of the New Hampshire
Association of criminal defense lawyers
um I guess the first thing I'd like to
say is obviously um you know when baale
reform first came about um and uh you
obviously was here during that practice
um we understood the main focus and the
primary focus um to be making sure that
people were not held on low amounts of
cash bail they were not held on low
amounts of cash bail um for you know
minor crimes such that poor people were
being held in jail for significant
sentences beyond anything they would
ever possibly face um as a sentence in a
case um simply because they did not have
the means um or the money to post bail
in a matter that substantially has gone
away I don't have clients um in those
situations due to bail reform and that's
significant um in this case and and
matters um because of the efforts of
this of this legislature and the work
that's been done on bail reform I
understand and I've followed obviously
as a practitioner over the years the
number of bail um the the number of
amendments that have to bail reform
issue and the reasons why um and I
actually appreciate uh attorney valard
raising an issue here um and agree with
him U we practice together a long time
and so um you know we know probably some
of the same people that we're talking
about here but when we're talking about
this um population um that is sort of
the ones that are um consistently coming
before the courts that are consistently
being arrested uh he used the term co-
co-occurring disorder and I just want to
make sure that everybody understands
exactly what that means in this
situation these are people who are are
suffering from um likely both uh
substance misuse disorders and
significant mental health conditions um
these are people who are you know we are
trying to help in our Comm in our
communities and I would note that you
know the battle on the opiate crisis
while long and hard we are gaining
ground the number of overdoses are down
in this state substantially um and it's
making a significant difference and so I
would say that this population is
challenging and and we do absolutely
understand that um in this situation but
these are folks who are struggling um
with these things and could greatly
benefit um from the services in the
community that are being provided so far
in terms of Community Mental Health
agencies um as well as access to
treatment the other thing I'll say is
overall my understands violent crime is
down in New Hampshire um and so this
response while I understand the number
of um you know uh people here who may be
sharing individual stories overall the
picture is that violent crime is down um
in New Hampshire this
um this committee and last year as well
put a lot I'm aware of work into a
significant compromise bill and I would
absolutely call it a compromise bill in
this situation um when looking at you
know what went into it the thought that
um specific crimes and specific violent
crimes were identified as really high
risk in the situation um and um the
significant consequences of people
violating bail when charged with those
types of crimes um is understandable and
it was probably inevitable that bail
reform would lead to that kind of
legislation um for those types of crimes
and so absolutely understandable uh but
the concern is that um you know at this
point we're going to get back caught up
again in uh people being held on amounts
of cash bail that they cannot post
because they do not have the means to do
so when people who do have means and
maybe um you know have committed the
same crimes or have the same criminal
history or have the same um you know uh
uh underlying conduct can be released in
these situations um you know we are
concerned obviously in the situation we
understand the failures to appear and
the concerns over the failures to appear
by the courts in these programs um there
have been efforts by the courts to deal
with this and so it's my understanding
there's a pilot program in Rockingham
County to start making um text messages
available to uh individuals in order to
remind them of their court dates you
know these are transient populations who
oftentimes um don't get mail and um
often times are unable to access
anything other than maybe um a text
message system when they have a Wi-Fi
connection which um fortunately is
around um so these are individuals who
can be reminded by the court by um some
pilot programs that are coming into
place I would say additionally it's my
understanding that there's a new system
that may make information about who
exactly is on bail um become more
available by entering it into the ncic
system that's incredibly important
because my experience in all of this is
you every iteration of bail reform
that's been concerned about people
committing crimes on bail the law has
already provided um the ability for
people's baales to be Revisited uh
amended and revoked is should they
violate their conditions of bail the
problem is finding you know is is
initiating that process making those
that underlying information known um and
I think alleviating some of the work on
prosecutors in these situations that
kind of system would make it known to
police officers and prosecutors who is
on bail in individual situations um and
make it more likely that you know the
types of motions that have always been
avail ailable and are currently
available under this law um uh can be
filed with a court and heard by a
magistrate or judge to make a
determination about bail in this matter
our position is that um you know the the
this the um bill that came through last
year through a lot of hard work by
everyone here um is just getting started
it's January 29th um and it started
January 1st these magistrates just got
to work we are currently um you know uh
working with them and seeing you know
what this system produces uh to not give
it the opportunity to do so we feel um
is sort of um unfortunate because uh
it's a bill that really tackles all the
complications um that bail reform
probably would probably did bring about
thank you for the opportunity to
speak thank you for coming to see us
today
turn it off good afternoon thank you Mr
chair thank you members of the committee
uh for the record on major Chris Bashaw
of the Rockingham County Sheriff's
Office uh and we are here in support of
uh the bill with the amendment as
proposed uh and supported by the
governor's office um there are some
you're going to hear stories of some of
the more egregious cases for some of the
very violent crimes people have been out
and reoffended I'm going to speak more
from a unique perspective of the
sheriff's office um and we get a lot we
get all the Superior Court warrants that
come from the uh Rockingham County New
Hampshire and we have to enter those and
we go out and try to affect those at any
given time we usually maintain anywhere
between a, 1200 uh active warrants from
the Superior Court uh and we track these
folks down all over the county all over
the state uh we extradite them from all
over the country uh depending on the
seriousness of the crime and since uh a
lot of the initiatives of bail reform
there have quite a few uh repeat
offenders and frequent flyers uh who
really just you know they've obviously
been able to manipulate the system and
fly in the face of law enforcement it's
uh very disheartening when you see
felony level cases uh and then new
warrants are coming out with judges
orders of to arrest for failures to
appear and they come to us and they're
already preset with a pre personal
recognizance bail even from the court on
these repeat offenders and these folks
are treating that might as well be a
late payment notice for your credit card
to some of these folks where they
actually laugh in the face of the
deputies when they show up and they say
Hey you know should I just have my ride
pick me up in 30 minutes we both know
I'm going to be out of here soon um so
it's it's very disheartening obviously
our folks always want to go out there
and do their job but when they continue
to see these folks uh can create some
dangerous situations as well because now
we do have an arrest warrant that's set
with a personal recogniz and bail but we
still have a duty to go affect that
arrest of warrant and some folks don't
want to be arrested on that even though
they probably will be processed and uh
out of there and bailed again uh within
30 minutes uh and it's created
situations that's put defendants at risk
where we have to forcibly remove them
they resist arrest they fight with our
deputies and local police officers so
there's a lot of situations where it's
created these problems and we just it's
really disheartening uh from our an
enforcement standpoint to do all this
work and tremendous resources as a
taxpayer uh it often you know flusters
me to see that we will fly all over the
country for some of these serious
offenses go through the process of
extradition Governor's warrants flying
out with multiple deputies to bring them
back from Texas California Florida uh in
other states and then you know pretty
shortly after they're released again on
personal recognising bail and we know
that they're in the wind so I know
you're going hear from some folks with
some specific and very egregious stuff
but I just really wanted to speak to the
some of the specifics that affect the
Sheriff's Office and all those judges
orders to arrest for violations and
failures to appear that are coming out
on a very regular basis uh and it it
and it it is disheartening to law
enforcement in general and as everyone
knows we have a national Recruitment and
Retention issue as it is uh and the last
thing we want to do is uh disenfranchise
those motivated law enforcement officers
that want to make our communities the
safer place to be thank you thank you
for sharing that unique perspective with
us major um I think I need to talk to
you about a budget yes sir we stick
around when we're done um the chair
aad okay let's see if the mic is right
okay um Amanda Zod policy director at
the ACLU of New
Hampshire chairman committee members
thank you for your time um many of you
know a great deal about baale and I
appreciate your work in this space I
have not had time to review the new
Amendment and I'm going to try to
respect the time of the committee since
this is a very busy hearing um so I've
cut back a little bit of what I had
planned to
say but first i' just like to step back
for an overview of why the bail process
is key to a just Criminal Justice System
bail is the process that determines
whether someone accused of a crime will
be incarcerated before their
trial baale is supposed to serve two
purposes here in New Hampshire
one to ensure that someone accused of a
crime will appear in court and two to
ensure that people who are a danger to
the community are detained even though
they have not been convicted of a
crime until bail reform in 2018
thousands of granite Staters were
incarcerated pre-trial each year not
because they were a danger to the
community but simply because they could
not afford to pay their
bail if you could afford bail you had a
very different experience I just want to
reflect on how far we've come
study after study shows pre-trial
detention increases recidivism rates
which means a person is more likely to
be arrested for a new crime we do not
want that of course pre-trial detention
has a host of other issues it makes it
more likely that innocent people will
plead
guilty people lose their employment
their income even their housing people
have their Liberty taken from them
before the criminal legal process has
even
begun being detained for any more than a
day is a traumatic family
disruption so the money bail system the
one that HB 592 initially and maybe
still hopes to return New Hampshire to
is a system that fuels widespread
wealth-based
incarceration for context pre-trial
incarceration caused unaffordable bail
for the context pre-trial incarceration
has caused unaffordable bail as the
single great greatest driver of
convictions and is responsible for the
bloating of our nation's jail and prison
populations meanwhile wealthy people as
was pointed out earlier accused of the
same crime can buy their freedom and
return home so with all that said New
Hampshire is better for its work to end
wealth-based incarceration bail reform
is an important piece making our
criminal legal system more about Justice
and ensuring each person in New
Hampshire feels that their Liberty and
freedom and legal rights
matter needlessly incarcerating people
for several days or with high bail not
based on ability to pay is detrimental
to families communities and cost
taxpayers a ton of money merely being
arrested is not supposed to result in a
person being incarcerated with limited
exceptions such as they are a danger to
our community our current process in New
Hampshire has that exact piece included
under our current system we are in a
good place HB 592 we are stepping far
back into the past and throwing out a
lot of good that's been done
here I also want to acknowledge the work
done by this committee progress on bail
last year was the result of years of
work by this group of people it was
months of bipartisan
negotiations and a bipartisan result
there were work sessions there there
were field trips there was stakeholder
buyin there was genuine real input from
law enforcement from courts from
stakeholders it was a very serious
process now we're only seven or eight
months out of Committee of conference
we're only 6 months from the governor
signing it and we're less than a month
from fully being
enacted and we're having this
conversation about potentially cutting
we need to let the new changes take
effect we need to let the magistrates
who have a five-year term do the work
that the legislators ask them to do and
I just want to remind everyone that the
magistrates is a cost-saving system as
well saving money by not incarcerating
people in jails for several days or more
that adds up very quickly but also as
mentioned earlier magistrates are paid
less than judges so if you're going to
get rid of them you're going to have
have judges doing the work at a higher
cost anyone who's a danger to the
community can be held currently if folks
violate a term of their release there
are options to hold them and decisions
around bail may be appealed by both
sides the system works so if it could
have more than a month to operate that
would be
best and lastly I just want to Let's
appreciate that New Hampshire is
incredible inedibly safe it is known as
one of the St safest states in the
country
repeatedly across the board according to
the Department of safety's website crime
was down from 2023 to
2024 so there is I want to be clear
there is no wave of crime that has
overtaken the state that merits tearing
up a brand new bipartisan deal on
bail in fact since bail reform has been
enacted over the years New Hampshire
continues to get safer looking at the
data all the way back to 2018 the first
year of bail reform crime has continued
to
drop we are continuously ranked as one
of the safest states in the country and
do not need to rip out bipartisan
criminal legal reform efforts out of our
laws and go
backwards bail reform has made our state
better over the years please don't go
backwards thank you for your
Sullivan good afternoon chairman Roy and
members of the committee my name is
Patrick Sullivan I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police I've
been actively involved and currently
serve in law enforcement for the past 43
3 years I retired as the police chief in
gtown I am here today to support HP 592
and its Amendment and for the New
Hampshire Association of chiefs police
for the most part this amendment
restores the statute to the bail back
prior to
2018 the purpose of bail has been a
legal process to allow the defendant to
be released from jail while awaiting
trial the other purpose of bail is to
ensure that the defendant appears in
court and does not
po uh POS a danger to the community
since the legislature made sweeping
changes to bail reform in 2018 signed by
the governor in 2018 there has been a
considerable frustration by all of law
enforcement about those who are not
being held who are a danger to the
public and the
community while well intended SB 556
went too far since 2018 there have been
many examples of how bail reform has not
worked and several changes made to
attempt to correct that
statute the New Hampshire Association of
CH police appreciate the governor
bringing this bill forward and we look
forward to working with the committee on
this
good afternoon Mr chair and committee
members my name is Chad Lavoy I'm a
major with the state police and I'm
representing the department of safety uh
from New Hampshire and the state police
as well and I'm here to offer testimony
and support of this bill and I'm not
going to repeat what my colleagues have
to say but I'll make it brief on where
we stand as an agency this change
simplifies as the bail process and
brings it back to where it was prior to
2018 our bail Commissioners are well
educated and experienced in the process
of representing the courts while
determining amount of bail our agency
has trust and confidence in their
ability to properly determine that bail
when they look at a multiple uh
different uh reasons whether that's
based on the level of crimes the history
with the defendant failure to
appears criminal history are they out on
bail right now and most importantly are
they a threat to themselves and to
Public Safety
overall this amendment will save us time
resources and money as an agency uh
already stretched thin our important
Focus right now is Public Safety and
being out there in a proactive
enforcement measure as a state agency we
cover multiple different courts in all
of our troop stations we have a process
with our prosecutors and our court
support staff and a trooper in each
troop that's designated to those courts
they work during the week Monday through
Friday as well with our prosecution
staff when there is something on the
weekend that needs to be done if a
defendant has a hearing on the weekend
now the way it's set up it's very t
taxing on us with resources getting
those reports if it's from a different
shift reviewing those reports and then
having that hearing during a designated
time is very taxing on our agency when
we like to best utilize our resources
out in the public view in the public eye
enforcing the laws of the state our goal
is to ensure that uh bail is appropriate
being set by the bail Commissioners and
the courts in a consistent and effective
manner to ensure that those that are
danger to themselves Us in law
accountable again our main focus is
Public Safety and it's for these reasons
and several that will be stated by my
colleagues today that we're in support
of this
amendment thank you major if I may ask
if you're aware where does the um the
information system stand right now as
far as um bail as knowing who's on bail
we allocated a significant amount of
money to that last year and I went to
every hearing to make sure that it
stayed in there um can you tell me where
it's at I don't have an update for you
right now on that sir but I can
certainly look into that and get back to
you on that I would appreciate it thank
you absolutely see you nothing further
thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else wishing
to testify on this bill who has not done
so see none I will hereby close the
public hearing I will be appointing a
subcommittee and that will be out before
all members we're going to be in in
recess for 15 minutes before we take up
session
e
thank you everyone I am now opening
executive session on House Bill 75 and I
recognize representative rhods to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move itl
for House Bill 75 I'll second that
motion thank you would you like to speak
to your motion sure
um unfortunately the sponsor was not
able to come testify on this bill and
our understanding is
is like usual we have several uh
cannabis bills coming towards us coming
towards us this session and our hopes is
maybe one of those May address what this
situation is or maybe they're going to
put this particular language with one of
those other
bills thank you would you like to speak
to your second representative Pro no
thank you thank you I would just say
that um it is true there are a matter of
fact we have a couple more Canabis
related bills um and I don't think that
it is um that high on either party's
priority list this year so I don't see
us spending a lot of time on that and as
I said the prime sponsor he may have
been traveling I'm not sure but someone
on the list could have come and no one
did so we give what we get um any other
comments or questions or discussion yes
represent Murray thank you Mr chair um I
will be voting for this today because I
always vote for expansion of cannabis in
the state and I do believe it should be
legalized and that we should have home
grow and hopefully we will see something
come out of the state house whatever it
may be I admire your principal stand
however we are going to roll over you
thank you very representative Sher I I
I'm going to join uh representative
Murray uh for the same set of principle
very
good I ask clerk to call the role motion
on floor is inexpedient to legislator
Vice chair roads yes representative pu
yes please representative LEL yes
representative
devoid yes representative gagy yes
representative pette yes representative
saor D yes representative Barry yes
representative Harriet
gther
no representative
muse no representative Newman no
representative Murphy no rep uh the
clerk votes no representative newel no
representative sheer no and chairman Roy
chotes yes
97 97 the motion itl passes um who will
Ally if I could get it by the end of the
weekend
please um and representative Ro you'll
write the majority
sure with that I close the executive
session on House Bill 75 I open the
executive session on House Bill 91 and
PR uh octop
pass wait
minut which one are we doing 91 91 which
one 91
91 that was a correct motion I believe
not not
911 second okay second okay motion was
seconded by representative pette would
you like to speak to your motion
Representative no I think it's pretty
simple it's just uh removing I I guess I
will talk it's just removing uh
the necessity for a fire department
detail to be there from the moment the
truck arrives with the fireworks until
they are all gone off and and put out um
it gives discretion to the fire
department which when they believe they
need to be there and only
that thank you representative
representative pette would you like to
speak to you a second no thank you uh I
would just add that this is a
cost-saving measure from alties who pay
for these um fire firemen to stand by um
sometimes overnight while fireworks on
the ground waiting to be lit um I think
that if I'm not mistaken the fire
departments themselves have supported
and asked for this bill is that correct
I believe so yeah so that's where that's
at any further
discussion see none asked the clerk call
the role the motion on the floor is
ought to pass Vice chair roads yes
representative
PR yes representative LEL yes
devoid yes representative gagy yes
representative pette yes representative
Sor diai yes representative Barry yes
representative Harry goth yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Shear yes chairman
Roy chair votes yes 160 160 any
objection to consent seeing none it will
go on the consent calendar with that I
hereby close House Bill 91
representative approve if I could get a
report by the end of the weekend please
um with that I open the executive
session on House Bill 183 and I
recognize representative approve for
motion uh ought to
pass second seconded by representative
pacquette would you like to speak to
your motion uh Yep this bill uh Works to
to uh remove the unfunded Mandate of
paying overtime when the call happens
close to the end of their shift which is
a rare occasion uh and this will
probably be just used for routine calls
any significant
call it they get done automatically uh
within 24 hours or even before they
leave so we'll still pay overtime for
those uh but it just uh a cost saving
measures on on the routine
calls thank you representative would you
like to speak to your second
Representative pqu no I agree with what
he said thank you representative Pro um
to the best of your knowledge was the
department or the State Fire Marshals
were they notified of this
bill uh yes they knew about it and did
anyone come or notify you that they were
against the
bill they said they weren't happy with
it but apparently not enough to show
up
yeah no he had discussed an amendment
but I think he just decided didn't need
it um it wasn't a wasn't a key amendment
I don't believe I think that there
saving something for possible use in the
politics yes
um I think the department of safety did
submit online testimony yeah
digitally
um is it long it's not super long I
don't
think um basically just
[Music]
says that the national trend for many
states is now requiring EMS records to
be submitted to the states within 24
hours of the event in a recent uh
meeting of the National Association of
State EMS officials and on the spot
survey of the 20 States reflected that
50% of them had a 24-hour or less
requirement of the New England states um
four out of five required 24 hours or
less um in addition New York require
submission within 4 hours so New
Hampshire Maine Vermont are all 24 Rhode
Island is 2 hours New York is 4 hours
Connecticut is 3 months Massachusetts is
Days
um this letter strongly encourages all
states to have requirements for data
submission within 24 hours a strongly
recommended documentation by legal
experts to reduce the likelihood of
omissions and or errors and
documentation um the state's EMS
software includes mechanism for
hospitals to receive these reports which
may be needed in a timely manner some
hospitals stipulate time frames for data
submission in their medical resource
Hospital agreements with licensed New
Hampshire EMS units EMS is also part of
the Health Care System its patient
records are medical records like any
of it's from the Department of Safety it
says division of fire standards and
training and Emer
represent would you like to um address
any of the comments made by the
department of safety fire
safety uh that's nice that they have uh
they want 24 hours but unless they're
paying my
overtime that's an unfunded mandate and
uh I don't believe we support those
thank
you um see no further discussion go
ahead raise your hand I don't think I
can support with this um when we had the
conversation um I believe at the time
that we that there was supposed to be an
amendment that's basically said that if
it was a delta or Echo it had to be done
immediately you couldn't wait the 24
hours we even talked about
um if letting the supervisor um make a
decision on some of those calls but I
know that I asked for 5 days versus
seven days but on the same token
if it's echo or Delta then it should be
24 hours and I thought we were going to
see an amendment that basically said
just that you like
the with such an amendment would you
support yeah we we said that
before um let me see how would we do
this logistically Nancy just so you know
my thought was I was going to leave it
this way so that when it got to the
Senate and the state finally showed
showed up and was gaming and hollering I
would have some bargain
chips so that's why I was leaving it
but
what yeah you can hold on to it we we
we'll carry it
to I think I'm going to do that because
I'm pretty sure eventually the state
will show up the thing I
that gives me no motivation sure they
did online testimony but they couldn't
be bothered to show up so obviously it's
not that important to them so that's the
way I see
that yeah thank you um I'm not sure why
they didn't show up it would have been
nice to see them here and have their
input but they clearly stated and shared
some information regarding other states
as well um I know I had raised the issue
of I thought it would be important to
have at least the Delta and Echo calls
done routinely I'm going to tell you
that happens without us doing that yes
but but should we change it we're saying
they don't they no longer have to be and
anybody that could choose for whatever
reason not to they' say look it there's
legislation I don't have to so I I get
it and I think most people doing their
job are going to do the right thing um
so I would not have objected to the bill
if we you know it was Delta and Echo
calls were done within 24 hours and the
other the remainder were maybe at the
discretion of the supervisor but I can I
I don't think a good support I get the
overtime savings but I think that's
something that management can can figure
and I it sort of bothers me to legislate
like policy and procedures within a
department when they're when the input
that they've
provided is consistent with other states
and this bill really isn't so just my
thoughts thank you so when it comes back
from the Senate and that amendment is on
it then you'll be supporting it right oh
there we go see everything works out
representative uh sherff I I was I was
thinking maybe we could do the Delta
Echo Amendment here and save the five
days for what happens in the Senate just
as a you know it save a little bit of a
oll I'm going to
roll looks like he pretty roll the
motion ask cler to call the roll of
motion on floor is ought to pass Vice
chair roads yes
representative PR yep representative LEL
yes representative devoid yes
representative gagy yes representative
pette yes representative saborn D yes
representative Barry yes representative
Harriet goth no representative
muse no representative Newman no
representative Murphy no the clerk votes
no representative Newell no
representative Shear no chairman Roy
chairs um 97 97 played a lot those are
numbers this
year um representative appr again a
report by the weekend police who's going
Report okay by the end of the weekend if
you don't
mind
with that I close the executive session
on House Bill 183 I open the executive
session on House Bill
416 and I
recognize representative samon D sh
motion to
retain
second motion to retain made by the
representative
Shon and seconded
by representative um roads would you
like to speak to your motion
representative yes I don't believe that
this legislation will
actually help reduce the sanal bacteria
plumes and I think that we're just
expanding basically state power into
people's properties I don't think that
this is actually going to get where
we're trying to go with it so wants to
solve one problem it's a punitive
solution but it's not actually going to
help us reduce the cyan
bacteria thank you representative um Ros
would you like to speak to your second
sure Mr chairman thank you um
the representative is correct and I
would like to
State I agree what was what was stated
at the hearing I I certainly do not
think that people should be uh putting
their their leaves their yard waste into
a river or into a lake um I also think
that we know we talk about a lot about
education and how things are enforced
and there was a lot of questions that
were not able to be answered at the
hearing and one of them was enforcement
I think that this this could probably be
dealt with with educ a and I would like
to go that route and I also um agree
with my colleague when he mentioned
about you know environmental
environmental legislation and and that
forth that might be the better route to
go so I think if we retain it um we can
see if we can get any input on that and
and take it up over the whenever we take
this up a summer or whenever that would
be thank you and that and that's
precisely why I did not want to itl this
bill I do think that it has worth um the
thought of somebody dumping stuff into a
lake grass or leaves just really makes
me unhappy so um I think that we need to
look at is this the right way to go
about that or should it be part of a
bigger picture so I actually do want to
look at this over the break um and learn
more about these cob bacteria thingies
myself because I don't know a lot about
them um any further
discussion seeing none ask cler call the
r motion of floors is to
retain Vice chair roads yes
representative PR nope representative
LEL yes representative devoid yes
representative Gagney yes representative
pette yes representative saborn D yes
representative Barry yes representative
Harriet
Gite
yes representative
Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative sheer yes chairman
Roy Geral yes
151 151 the motion carries any objection
to
consent hey you objection consent no
okay it will go on consent if you could
give me just a little blow by the
weekend
please um let me see
report I don't believe retained bills go
on a consent calendar I think they're
just retained by the committee yeah I
think you're right I forgot it was a
retained is retained by the committee I
still we still need a report to go on a
calendar yeah all right with that um I
hereby close the executive session on
House Bill po wait a minute uh oh oh
before I dropped the hammer I
retain oh it no we're holding on to it
going it's closed bills retained and you
get out of the report magic and with
that I open the executive session of
hpit 196 I recognize myself for a motion
I move inexpedient to legislate I'll
the no you
you it's next U Mr chair was a uh if I
could please this was a this was I just
made a a grievous area this bill was not
um this bill was accidentally put on
here it's not supposed to be here I
withdraw my motion to um itl who made
the second I'll withdraw it as well it's
withdrawn in that executive session is
hereby close um I open executive session
on House Bill 291 and recognizing myself
for a motion on that one and I say ought
to
pass oh and I'll
Amendment do
it yes
Mr chairman yeah Mr chairman you don't
have to withdraw your motion you can
just move an amendment on top of a not
to pass
you
second that's me thank you Mr chair um
I'd like to move amendment number
2025-the
um uh there was the
violation removing the penalties that
were were in law currently um and as uh
has been mentioned about other
environmental um legislation part of the
the uh way to
to
encourage citizens to be good stewards
of our of our environment is education
um we also spoke with uh uh trying to
think of the person from the uh Lakes
Association and um they agreed that part
of the um the information that they
provide to uh Property Owners around
Lakes uh it it includes things like
changes in in law um this amendment
changes the
um changes the penalty the the penalties
and would change it to should a a person
or the corporate agent so if a a person
hired just say say I don't know ABC
company um the upon that first initial
incorrect application either the wrong
uh the wrong fertilizer or um in a
fertilizer incorrectly applied they
would receive a warning for the first
offense uh both the the homeowner and
the the agent that um did the um did the
application the second time they would
be guilty of a violation and subject to
a $250 fine per acre just just for the
second offense and the a misdemeanor for
third or subsequent offense there is a
huge cost to tourism Lakes are um fish
um I know there are there are um land
owners that have some camps around lakes
and they can't have kids um swim in the
water if they're cyano bacteria so this
would um go a long way in uh reminding
people and I think people try to do the
right thing when they know about it and
I I think that the um Lakes Association
would do a really good job of of um
helping spread the information and um
around the this proposed
amendment thank you representative um
representative
Pro so I agree with most of that
except for the agent part right if
you're a professional landscaping
company you should know
this so I think they should get a
violation for a
shot right joku citizen I'm okay with a
with a a warning the first time
violation the second time and the rest
of that but I'm thinking the agent who's
a professional should know what they're
doing and if they're doing it they're
president
Newman yeah I I was going to say I would
think that um having the fine $250
doesn't sound like a big deal but if
you're a large company and you're doing
a lot of lakefront homes you could rack
up a lot of $250 fines in one day and
essentially get to number three
misdemeanor very quickly so I you know I
I I understand and I I agree that those
people that citizens entrust to do the
right thing um have somewhat of more of
a responsibility but I feel like if the
if this would this would release any um
chance of well it's the home owner's
fault they told me or the um the uh
agent saying uh you know whose
responsibility is it it takes it all out
makes things consistent there's no
unknowns um and I think when a a company
um you know is known as violating this
it impacts business as well
so I think for simp Simplicity sake it's
representative Newman I just have
parlamentary inquir you going to restate
the motion and all of that sort that out
in a minute um this is why it chose
criminal justice because we're always
steeped in manure no
um okay so right now we're going to be
voting on is a motion to adopt want to
what resp never mind just vote on it
okay it is getting close to four o'clock
um we're going to motion to adopt the
amendment correct
yes who did oh I'm sorry Rich did you
want to say
something I was going to withdraw it I I
tend to agree with this amendment I'm
reminded of uh the fact that significant
fertilizer for anything other than food
or for Animals is uh
amendment thank you uh with that I ask
the cour to call the
rule Vice chair
roads yes representative PR nope
representative LEL yes representative
devoid yes representative gagy yes
representative pette yes representative
Sabor D yes representative Barry yes
representative harri GTH yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative sheer yes and
chairman Roy chair votes yes
any new any new
motions yeah with my bed any any new
motions representative Murphy do you
have a motion I move a of pass as
amended Thank You seconded by
representative here at gath right um any
new discussion new new insights in the
last couple seconds seeing none I would
ask clerk to call the rooll uh motion on
the floor is ought to pass Amendment
Vice chair roads yes representative
PR uh no representative LEL yes
representative devoid yes representative
gagy yes representative pette yes
representative Sabor D yes
representative Barry yes representative
Harry gother yes representative Muse yes
representative Newman yes representative
Murphy yes the clerk votes yes
representative newel yes representative
of Shear yes and chairman Roy chairold
yes 151 151 motion carries uh any
objection to consent no seeing none
it'll go on consent um represent approve
I need a Minority Report by the end of
the weekend no minority yeah I'm going
to need one and with that I close the
executive session and I open the
57 represent Muse would you like to make
a motion on that
yes I would Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion uh of L to
pass second by representative Murray
motion this is a bill that was uh that I
was actually asked to file by the
Department of Corrections and what it
would do is it would uh change uh the
parameters of alternative home
confinement uh so that people who want
to take uh Secondary College courses
uh in the uh or secondary posteducation
courses uh in the towns where they're
confined are uh are actually able to do
that so this is something that um has
potential um you know to be
life-changing for some of for people who
basically are among the most qualified
people uh to be eligible for release uh
so these are these are people who who
basically um the uh Department of
Corrections itself uh is willing to uh
to gamble on these are folks that have
been approved for alternative home
confinement um and uh essentially these
are folks who are uh either monitored
directly by the department or or who
have some type of uh electronic
monitoring device they are only uh uh
allowed to go outside their homes uh for
things like uh employment opportunities
uh uh and I think I believe public
service jobs uh as well now this would
actually expand it to uh post-secondary
educational opportunities where this can
come up as a practical matter sometimes
is if you look at uh places like the
Portsmouth Naval Shipyard that's over
near where I am um they have
apprenticeship programs that actually uh
require uh folks to uh to work on site
at the shipyard uh at at times uh but
there there are also courses uh that
people are required to take uh as part
of that over at Granite community
community college so not quite sure how
how many uh Blended opportunities there
are but there's a really practical
example of where a bill like this uh
could really help some could maybe be
the difference between uh somebody being
able to transition smoothly into life
outside of prison um and not be at risk
to go back to prison uh
versus may be increasing that risk a
little bit so uh again this was
requested by the uh by the Department of
Corrections and uh and I hope you'll
support it thank you representa would
you like to speak to your second
represent Murray um just to say that I
definitely think we should be passing
any legislation that can help reduce
recidivism I agree any further
discussion actually I have a question
yes is uh is it is this for like online
school only or is that they can go out
to a you would be able to do either you
would be able to go online or you would
be able to go out into the to community
the thing is is the way alternative home
confinement works is you have to be back
in your house by a specific time of of
of the day if you're not you're in
violation of your terms and they can
take you back this is something they
already do if you have an for instance
there's a there's a job that you have
outside currently our statute only
allows it for uh you know for employ
employment uh or for uncompensated
public service okay so so this would
basically you know give somebody the
option to do something like you know
take a business course take a course
that's necessary for an apprenticeship
that type of thing thank you represent M
and thank you chairman Roy no
problem any further seeing none I ask
the clerk to call the role the motional
floors ought to pass Vice chair roads
yes representative
PR yep representative
yes representative devoid yes
representative gagy yes representative
pette yes representative suborn D Shai
yes representative Barry yes
representative Harriet GTH yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Shear yes chairman
Roy chot yes 160 160 unanimously passes
any objection to consent see none it
goes on
consent and who actually made that
representative Muse if you could by the
end of the weekend a report please and
with that um thank you all very much I
want to just note that we are continuing
on with uh the progress we made last
year as far as the number of unanimously
passed bills regardless of the numbers
on either side so let's keep that up and
com